messieurs donc Vincent Labrune et Arnaud
rouget respectivement président et
directeur général de la Ligue de
football professionnel ainsi que
Frédéric benier directeur de
l'Association des ligues de sport
professionnel monsieur je vous souhaite
la bienvenue messieur plutôt je vous
souhaite la bienvenue et vous remercier
de votre disponibilité pour répondre à
nos questions nous avons entamé les
travaux de cette commission d'enquête
sur l'identification des défaillances de
fonctionnement au sein des fédérations
françaises de sport du du monde sport SP
et des organismes de gouvernance du
monde sportif le 20 juillet dernier nos
travaux portent sur trois axes les
violences physiques sexuelles ou
psychologiques dans le sport les
discriminations sexuelles et raciales et
les problématiques liées à la
gouvernance monsieur le Président vous
avez notamment été président de l'OM
vous êtes entré en septembre 2011 au
conseil d'administration de la LFP
pardon en septembre 2020 le conseil
d'administration vous élit président
depuis cette date vous êtes membre de
droit du commex de la FFF dont plusieurs
dysfonctionnements ont été longuement
évoqués
oui moqué devant cette commission
d'enquête je rappelle que la FFF et la
LFP sont liés par une convention de
subdélégation qui définit les relations
entre les partis et les compétences
qu'elles exersent en commun Monsieur le
Directeur Général de la LFP vous avez
occupé les fonctions de directeur des
compétitions de l'fp de 2003 à 2023
cette direction est notamment chargée
d'assurer le bon déroulement des
compétitions le le 17 septembre 2020 le
conseil d'administration de la LFP a
décidé de vous nommer sur proposition de
Monsieur Vincent lbrrune directeur
général de laalfp l'Association
nationale des ligues de sport
professionnels défend les intérêts
communs de laalfp et des ligues
nationale de basketball de de cyclisme
de handball de rugby et volet ces ligues
regroupent plus de 160 clubs et équipes
professionnelles Monsieur Frédéric Bier
je signale que vous avez avait été le de
juillet 2013 à mars 2014 conseiller
sport professionnel de la ministre des
Sports Valérie fouon fourniron messieurs
dans un bref propos liiminaire
pouvez-vous présenter les relations
entre les ligues professionnelles et les
fédérations sportives délégataire et
présenter les rôles de chacun dans les
domaines qui intéressent notre
commission d'enquête à cet égard
monsieur le Président la brune nous
souhaiterions que vous commenciez par
revenir sur les dysfonctionnements dont
vous avez naissance au sein de la FFF je
vous rappelle que cette audition est
ouverte à la presse et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale avant de vous
laisser la parole et d'entamer nos
échanges je vous rappelle que l'article
6 de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relatif au fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impos aux personnes
entendues par une commission d'enquête
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité je
vous invite donc chacun votre tour à
lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure à après avoir activé votre micro je
le
jure je le jure non al il faut désacti
votre micro voilà je le
jure je j très bien Messieurs je vous
laisse la
parole madame la présidente Madame la la
rapporteur madames et Messieurs les les
députés bon bonsoir merci déjà d'avoir
accepté le le report euh du premier
rendez-vous prévu
initialement j'ai une petite question
suite à à votre à votre introduction on
nous avait dit qu'on pouvait faire un
petit propos liminaire concernant notre
activité avant de répondre plus
concrètement à vos questions et ça me
semblait utile de le faire je vais
essayer de le faire vite pour pas vous
faire perdre de temps pour remettre en
perspective le l'action qu'on a mené à
la LFP et depuis 3 ans et surtout qui je
suis donc moi Vincent Labrune je suis né
en 71 à Orléan un père expert comptable
une mère professeur j'ai travaillé 15
ans dans l'industrie des médias j'ai
rejoint effec comme vous venez famille
drefus ensuite pour gérer leurs intérêts
au sein de de l'Olympique de Marseille
avec
robertrefususquen 2009 puis avec sa
veuvre suite à son d jusqu'en 2016 j'ai
été effectivement comme l'avz précisé
membre du conseil d'administration sans
discontinuer depuis 2011 550 tant que
représentant de l'EM et depuis 2016 en
tant que que membre indépendant c'est
dans ce contexte que j'ai décidé de me
présenter en septembre 2020 à la
présidence de la LFP avec un objectif
très clair qui était de réformer en
profondeur notre organisation et nos
compétitions de fer de façon de PER à la
France de rayonner à l'international à
travers aussi les performances de de ces
équipes de football européennes en
essayant de mettre les football de club
au niveau de de ces sélections
nationales je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent que la société est fracturée que
la société est divisé que le football
féire est uni et que les grandes épopées
footballistiques permettent de
rassembler les gens comme on a pu le
voir récemment à Toulouse récemment
après la performance du TFC contre
contre Liverpool donc j'ai été élu à la
présidence de la FP en septembre en
pleine crise sanitaire qui avait conduit
à l'arrêt des compétitions par le
Premier ministre devant l'Assemblée
nationale le 28 avril 2022 avec pour
conséquence une première difficulté
économique liée au non paiement de la
fin de saison par les diffuseurs à la
mise en place d'un PSG de 225 millions
d'euros 15 jours après mon élection
malheureusement on a eu la déférience de
notre partenaire majur audiovisuel Mia
pro qui s'est placé sous la protection
du tribunal de commerce et on est donc
rentré très vite dans le vif du sujet
avec Arnaud et nos équipes dès l'automne
2020 pour sortir de méia pro qui voulait
évidemment négocier de Rabé en menant
parallèlement pendant le confinement
deux actions concrètes une réforme de la
gouvernance vous venez de le dire
séparation des rôles président-
directeur général
et mise en place d'un syndicat unique de
façon à à fédérer et réunir les clubs
qui était quelque chose d'important
l'unité des clubs dans le cadre de de
projet et deuxièmement on a fait
également la mise en place je suis
désolé c'est pas le sujet mais je
voulais quand même vous le dire pour
contextualiser la mise en place d'une
ligne de crédit avec JP Morgan pour 120
million d'euros avant à rembourser avant
juin 2021 pour sauver la trésorerie des
clubs et le nonversement de l'échance
média pro d'octobre au cours de l'hiver
20 2020 du printemps 21 on s'est
concentré sur la commercialisation des
droits audiovisuels avec le groupe Canal
Plus pour la fin de saison négociation
complexe en raison de de l'amertume pour
pas dire de de l'aigreur du groupe Canal
plus à l'égard du du football français
suite à la perte des droits en 2018 et
dans un second temps on a finalisé la
commerciation droit cette fois jusqu'en
2024 avec un nouvel entant qu'on a
réussi de convaincre qui est le le Gafa
Amazon donc en fait le football
professionnel est passé d'une expérence
de gain de 1,306 milliards d'euros pour
la plupart dépassé dépensé par les clubs
une réalité économique de 734,5 millions
d'euros soit une perte annuelle de 571
millions d'euros face à ce triple
tsunami arrêt du championnat crise du
covid défaillance de médiia pro avec un
effondrement des droits télé qui est un
cas j'insiste unique en Europe je tiens
à le rappeler puisque c'est pas arrivé à
nos concurrents nos concurrents ils ont
juste à géré la crise du covid un choix
fort a été effectué de façon à réformer
le football professionnel en général et
en profondeur le passage 18 clubs c'est
du sportif passe vite les travaux sur la
société commerciale c'est de
l'économique le développement de des
relations avec l'État dans le sens d'une
meilleure coordination avec eux la
poursuite de la réforme de la
gouvernance de la de la LFP et la mise
en place de la politique intégrité de la
LFP alors après viennent les saisons ça
va vous intéresser un peu plus 21 22 22
23 fin du confinement retour du public
dans les stades là on a marqué par une
résurgence de phénomène violent dès dès
la reprise du championnat et la sortie
du confinement Nice Marseille bagarre
rangé sur le terrain lyonmseille
bouteille jetée sur la tête de Dimitri
paayette même en Ligue 2 nonan que Vili
je rentre pas dans détail et surtout le
erreur absolue le Saint-Étienne aosser
de de fin de saison où face à la
déception sans doute de la relégation
mais pas que parce que les gens sont
idiots des centaines de de de pseudo
supporters des voyous sont rentrés sur
le terrain pour s'en prendre ni plus ni
moins au public on a frôé la catastrophe
et on a failli avoir avoir un mort donc
on a pris immédiatement ce ce ce
phénomène à bras le corp dès euh le mois
suivant dans une intervention à
l'Assemblée fédérale de Nice le 18 juin
2022 dont nous vous transmettrons une
copie intégrale à l'issue de cette
audition j'ai fait pour résumer la
déclaration suivante il faut que dans
les semaines et mois qui viennent que
chacun son niveau soit courageux pour
mettre ses criminels où il doit être en
aucun cas dans les stades de football
dès le 30 juin 2022 nous avons lancé le
rapport Boher sur stème de la violence
pour une remise rapide à l'entrée de la
saison 2223 Alain Boher qui est un
professeur en criminologie est intervenu
au conseil d'administration du 30
septembre 2022 ilarmé son rapport
définitif le 23 novembre 2022 et on a
d'ailleurs observé une baisse sensible
desffits de violence grave sur la saison
2223 qui a suivi je laisserai Arnaud
vous le commenter ultérieulement dans le
même temps on a finalisé finaliser nos
travaux de la société commerciale on a
renforcé la stratégie RSE de la LFP en
intégrant ces critères RSE dans la
licence club et en insistant tout
particulièrement sur les questions de
discrimination et transition écologique
on a enfin mis en place la cét
commerciale avec le recrutement d'un DG
d'un certain nombre de collaborateur de
haut niveau on a mis en place les
ressources nécessaires on a aujourd'hui
145 personnes au sein de la structure
contre 80 il y a moins de 2 ans en
synthèse et j'ai fait le plus rapidement
possible bonsoir Monsieur depuis le 10
septembre la LFP et le football
professionnel ont fait face à une crise
économique et financière sans précédent
pour y faire face nous avons décidé de
conduire un chantier de réforme
ambitieux inédit de façon à nous
permettre d'affronter avec plus de force
et de souplesse l'environnement complexe
pour pas dire anxiogène auquel nous
étions et auxquel nous sommes toujours
d'ailleurs confrontés ce chantier de
réforme a mobilisé l'ensemble de
l'écosystème dans une transparence
totale il a impliqué l'état la
Fédération Française les clubs nos
partenaires syndicaux pas moins de 111
réunions d'assemblée générale de
conseiladministration de collègees Ligue
1 Ligue 2 ont été organisé pour
traverser la cuire la crise et conduire
les réformes et améliorer notre football
depuis le début de mon mandat enfin sur
le sujet majeur et prioritaire à mes
yeux de la violence dans les stades et
de la lutte contre les discrimination
nous avons opté pour une politique de
tolérance zéro on est totalement lié
avec la ministre des Sports sur ce
point-là avec trois piliers essentiels
petit 1 la sensibilisation et
coordination de nos actions avec l'État
petit 2 le renforcement de nos actions
disciplinaires et l'encouragement des
actions judiciaires à ce titre je tiens
à préciser pour rappel si nécessaire que
la commission de discipline de la LFP
est sans doute les les plus répressives
en Europe et petit 3 enfin une une
communication grand public sur
l'ensemble des questions de
discrimination que je laisserai Arnaud
vous détailler plus tard voilà j'ai fait
le plus rapidement possible sur le
propos introductif euh je vous réponds
tout de suite sur le
reste Fédération Française de
Football voilà
donc je me suis présenté quelques jours
si j'étais le candidat surprise à
l'élection de septembre il y avait qu'un
seul candidat qui était un éminemment
respectable Michel deniso qui était le
candidat de la
Fédération céit le candidat de la
fédération candidat unique soutenu par
les gros clubs en l'occurrence olympique
lon le
parisintgermain et j'étais donc le
candidat antiystème j'ai été élu à la
surprise générale et ça a pas été
forcément vu et perçu comme une une
bonne nouvelle au niveau de de de la
Fédération on avait des relation assez
éloignée avec Noë ler j'ai même été à
l'époque où j'étais pr en le un des plus
grands soutiens de Frédéric thries qui
était son opposant politique majeur mais
ceci étant dit je dois dire que j'ai
donc appris à à connaître Noël B dans
les jours qu'on suivi puisqu'on doit
collaborer ensemble et on a bien
fonctionné on on a bien fonctionné en en
bonne intelligence on avait une crise
vraiment majeure je tiens à le signer à
signaler à affronter ensemble euh il
nous a beaucoup aidé il a été de bons
conseil il a il a beaucoup plus
d'expérience que que nous et que moi en
l'occurrence et il a joué un rôle actif
y compris dans un point encore une fois
qui est pas le sujet du jour mais qui
est important pour nous qui était de
créer la société commerciale pour
apporter des fonds pour sauver nos clubs
donc on a on a bien travaillé ensemble à
titre personnel mes relations avec la
Fédération une fois que j'ai dit tout ça
pris par le quotidien avec les club se
limite à une réunion mensuelle dans une
réunion que vous connaissez maintenant
qui s'appelle le commex en présence des
élus où sont abordés un certain nombre
de sujets très transverses qui touchent
majoritairement le le football le le
football amateur et je n'ai pas eu état
n'étant pas proche de la fédération de
fait euh grave ou gravissimes avant la
publication d'articles dans la presse je
de mémoire septembre octobre
euh septembre 2022 octobre
2022 et malgré la la relation de de
confiance que nous avions établie avec
la Fédération Française de Football j'ai
une bonne surprise d'ailleurs pour moi
je le cache pas professionnel j'ai été
celui qui a dit dès le janvier 2021 que
quand la question du maintien à son
poste de Monsieur le Red se posait le
statut quo n'est pas une option non pas
parce que je le considérais coupable de
quoi que ce soit j'en savais strictement
rien mais tout simplement parce que
j'accorde une très grande importance à
l'image du football français nous je
pense qu'on est là pour pour réformer
pour innover pour moderniser et on avait
une telle pression politique et
médiatique sur ce sujet que que
effectivement je considérais que le
président leraette nonobstant ce qu'on
pouvait lui reprocher pouvait
malheureusement pas pas rester en place
et nous avons participé à à changer
l'organisation le monde professionnel en
en soutenant la candidature de la
personne qui nous semblait la plus
idoinee pour assurer la période de
transition des 18 mois à venir qui était
monsieur Dialo voilà je peux rentrer
plus dans le détail si vousmême rentrer
plus dans le détail parce que
je la répartition des rôles répartition
ouis complète parce que je parti un peu
ah
pardon sur votre sur votre question sur
la répartition des rôles comme vous le
savez effectivement et et Fred pourra
compléter sur les autres ligues mais les
les les ligues professionnelles gèent la
partie professionnelle par délégation
des fédérations donc à ce titre on
organise on gère on réglemente le la
Ligue 1 et la Ligue 2 par des délégation
de la FD ce qui veut dire assez
concrètement on organise les calendriers
on homologue les contrats de joueurs on
gère la discipline en première instance
en appel c'est la Fédération comme on
gère le le contrôle de gestion en
première instance en appel c'est la
Fédération globalement le pouvoir
d'appel reste à la Fédération et on on
gère en en première instance les
l'organisation de nos disciplines on
définit le calendrier en programme les
matchs et puis Vincent l'a souligné
maintenant c'est plus clair avec la la
création de la filiale commerciale on
commercialise également les droits
l'ensemble des droits qu'on appelle
l'exploitation de nos compétitions VO
mais ce qui est formation des éducateurs
formation des jeunes joueurs tout ça
relève de la DTN de la Fédération euh
comme le sport amateur relève de la
Fédération
voilà pour compléter les les cliques
professionnelles qui sont effectivement
toutes dotées du même statut juridique
qui sont des statuts juridiques propres
et qui ont effectivement une une gestion
en en en autonomie administrative et
financière et elles remplissent les
mission que Arnaud vient d'indiquer ce
qui est aussi important de savoir c'est
queeffectivement de facto nous n'avons
pas le développement des pratiques qui
qui concernerait effectivement le sport
masculin et le sport féminin on a
effectivement en délégation
subdélégation des fédérations des
compétitions masculines euh pour les
première et 2e division de masculin
hormis la Ligue de volet qui a également
la première division euh féminine et
pour ce qui est de la question
disciplinaire rano vous l'a
expliqué l'organisation est que les les
comités éthiques et déontologie sont les
mêmes c'est les comités éthiques et
déontologie de la fédération et qui
effectivement est unique par rapport à
l'ensemble de la discipline et qui
couvre aussi la ligue professionnelle
toutes nos ligues professionnelles sont
gérées couvertes par le comité éthique
et de déontologie de la
Fédération juste une question est-ce
est-ce que vous pouvez revenir sur votre
partenariat avec colosse au pied
d'argile alors colosse au pied d'argile
pour la Ligue voulaz dire he la Ligue de
football c'est un partenariat récent
qu'on a signé au mois de juin de mémoire
pour alors de mémoire je vous donnerai
plus de plus de précision sur cette
question si vous le souhaitez pour
intervenir et faire des séances de
sensibilisation au niveau au niveau des
clubs la première a eu lieu à Toulouse
récemment et même
si on a des populations moins nombreuses
que les fédérations on estime que sur la
question des des violences sexuelles et
sexistes on doit aussi s'impliquer sur
des questions de sensibilisation et on a
signé un partenariat avec eux parce que
c'est eux qui nous semble être le mieux
à même compte tenu de leur maillage et
de leur capacité à faire de la
sensibilisation de répondre à ce
besoinl
est-ce que vous pouvez revenir sur la
multiplication des comportements des
viens au cours des deux dernières
saisons un rapport d'Aba conseil de
novembre 2022 a avancé que les
changements de comportement observés
dans la société avaient trouvé je cite
une déclinaisons particulière dans les
stades de football en l'occurrence des
comportements de défoulement ou
désinhibés surtout les agressivités et
les frictions ne seraiit plus le lot des
seules tribunes d'ultra mais désormais
de toutes les tribunes vous nous avez
indiqué tout à l'heure vous aviez
constater cette recrue d'essence que
vous étiez sur une tolérance zéro mais
du coup comment ça se décline
concrètement comment faire en sorte
justement que le football ne devienne
pas le défouloir de notre
sociétéjà déjà je suis d'accord avec le
le point euh est-ce qu'il y a de la
violence dans dans dans le football il y
en a évidemment mais comme il y en a
dans la société est-ce qu'il y a du
racisme dans le football il y en a
évidemment comme il y en a est-ce qu'il
y a de l'homophobie on faut bien sûr
qu'il y en a combi d'Ann cité puisque
pour revenir sur le votre étude d'AB
conseil je l'ai toujours dit je l'ai dit
depuis 20 ans pour moi le football c'est
le reflet de de l'état de la société
et on va pas tout arrêter tout seul mais
c'est notre mission notre devoir de
faire le maximum pour y
participer ce que j'ai pas observé par
contre c'est euh des comportements
déviants en hausse hors zone ultra
supporter ça je peux pas m'exprimer
là-dessus euh donc sur ces points là
Arnaud va vous faire la réponse on est
quand même sur des sanctions très très
répressives euh à l'échelle de la
commission de discipline je rappelle
qu'on a pas de pouvoir de police ou de
justice à la Ligue on est au départ euh
contraint par des par des procédures qui
sont majoritairement collectives de
sanctions collectives donc on a
multiplié euh non seulement les
fermetures de tribunes mais où on est
allé très très loin c'est qu'on a voulu
envoyer un message fort au club mais
surtout aux supporters en commençant à
enlever des points à leur équipe il y a
très peu de ligues qui font ça je peux
vous dire que c'est pas très populaire
comme comme mesure euh auprès de
personne et on a commencé à à
sanctionner durement en enlevant des
points du classement aux équipes dont
les comport dont les supporters se
comportaient de façon exagérer de façon
à ce que eux-mêmes comprennent que
c'était leur club qui allait en pâtir la
limite de ce
raisonnement moi je suis assé jusqu'au
boutiste en plus dans ma vision des
choses c'est que si on tire trop sur
laaccorde là-dessus il y aura plus de de
championnat au niveau sportif on va
faire le classement dans la commission
de discipline donc voilà ce que je
voulais dire moi en terme de philosophie
parce que là je je suis là moi pour
fixer c'est un cap et on veut être
intransigent et surtout il y a de la
violence partout il y a encore eu de la
violence cette nuit brésil-argentine
dans les tribunes une BAGAR général
incroyable dans le football mais c'est
pas pour ça qu'on doit pas essayer
d'être différent et qu'on doit pas
essayer d'être référent donc nous on a
envie que notre diversité nos
différences deviennent notre richesse et
notre atout et si on peut demain être
une ligue moteure et une ligue
différente des autres sur le racisme sur
lesffet de racisme en ce moment je suis
assez content de ce qui se passe chez
nous on est plutôt mieux que les autres
on a pas tout fait on peut faire mieux
mais je pense que si la Ligue française
arrive à être référente mondialement
c'est ça participera aussi à nous élever
en tant que Ligue en tant que sport en
tant que nation et à nous faire briller
à l'international comme je vous l'ai dit
aussi tout à l'heure en ouverture on
doit briller par nos résultats on doit
briller aussi par qui on est on est et
on est différent on doit l'être en tout
cas vous faites vous faites référence au
rapport d'Alain Bauer effectivement le
rapport d'Alain Bauer il arrive à un
moment assez particulier particulier
dans le sens où personne ne l'avait
connu avant c'est la sortie du
confinement et en fait la sortie du
confinement il y a un élément important
qui est à souligner c'est que les
phénomènes de violence étaient traités
avant quand il y a des des
interpellations vous avez le dispositif
d'interdiction de stade qui entent en
jeu sauf que les interdictions de stade
ont une durée limitée et finalement on
s'est retrouvé à la sortie du
confinement et c'est ce que pointe Alain
ber dans son rapport avec un double
effet finalement une une une diminution
extrêmement forte sur les années 19 20
20 21 du nombre d'interdictions de de
Sade qu'ell soit judiciaire ou
administrative avec dans le même temps
une perte non pas de compétenence mais
d'habitude ou d'usage de toutes les
équipes de sécurité qu'ell soi publique
ou privé puisque tout tout le T tous les
effectifs étaient restés l'arme au pied
pendant un certain temps ou même avait
été avait trouvé du travail ailleurs ce
changeant de d'orientation
professionnelle et donc finalement à
l'ouverture de la
saison 20 21 22 et le retour du public
on a dû faire face effectivement à des
phénomènes de violence assez majeure que
Vincent a cité dans son introduction et
qui ont conduit à à une à une une un
audit extérieur que l'on a souhaité par
un expert en la en la matière pour voir
quelle préconisation on pouvait faire et
en quoi les préconisations qu'il pouvait
formuler nous étions en capacité de les
mettre en œuvre et puisque vous l'avez
vous nous avez demand de vous le
remettre vous avez vu qu'il y a un
certain nombre de de préconisations qui
sont formulées derrière on s'est emparé
de ces de ces préconisation on a mis en
place un groupe de travail pour
travailler sur chacune d'elles et en
lien avec l'État et avec les clubs
essayer de faire des propositions mais
j'imagine que vous allez rentrer dans le
détail ou sinon je vous développe les
les les ce que nous avons fait sur la
base de ce rapport
dites-moi soit je développe les
préconisations soit vous vous avez des
questions spécifiques vous voulez sur le
rapport
[Musique]
Bower dites-moi ok ce qu'on fera c'est
que sur les préconisations vous n Les
enverrez par contribution écrite VO tout
fa avec et et du coup on va continuer
les
question un fait tu l'as dit je crois de
on avait plus d'interdiction du stade
les mecs avaient purgé donc on s'est
retrouvé avec un on s'est retrouvé avec
un taux de personnes complètement cinglé
au-dessus de la moyenne dans le stade
c'est une conversation que j'ai eu très
vite avec le ministre
Blanquer de mémoire c'est fin 2021 on
s'était vu on s'était croisé un soir au
stade il m'avait dit qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire et de façon complètement
subjective cert j'avais dit je pense
qu'il y a il y a à peu près il y a à peu
près 1000 personnes à interdire de stade
ça fait une cinquantaine par club c'est
50 personnes al c'est beaucoup et c'est
peu à la fois c'est une cinquantaine de
personnes par club qui n'ont rien à
faire dans not tribune et si on arrive à
faire 50 x 20 é= 1000 et que c'est 1000
individus dans dangereux qui de mon
point de vue sont d'ailleurs les mêmes
qui vont tout casser à la manif du 1er
mai accessoirement si on arrive à sortir
ces gens des stades ils sont revenus
dans les
stades la situation devrait pouvoir
s'améliorer
ustrer ce que dit Vincent on pourra vous
les remettre même si c'est des données
qui qui appartiennent plutôt au
ministère de l'Intérieur et qui sont
plutôt à la main de l'État donc on
a on prend on enregistre ce qui nous
communique on va dire fin 2021 on était
au total interdiction judiciaire et
administrative de stade autour de
77 aujourd'hui on est à
214 ça peut paraître une augmentation
importante c'est effectivement x 3 par
rapport à à 2021 mais on était à plus de
339 pardon juste avant le covid
donc qui ce qui est assez faible par
rapport à ce qu'on estime devoir être
les les voyou sortis des
stades
peut-être sur la question précise de
l'interdiction des stades si vous pouvez
nous préciser comment ça fonctionne
parce que sur le dernier match omol
oui je crois que c'était ça il y avait
justement des supporters qui étaient
interdits à Lyon mais pas à Marseille
donc voilà si vous pouvez nous expliquer
quels sont les limites du
dispositif alors en fait il y a c'est
dans le dans le dans dans le rapport
Bower vous le verrez il y a la première
je fais juste une parenthèse pour
introduire et répondre à la question que
vous m'avez
posé dans le rapport Bower la première
phase c'est clarifier les relations
entre l'État et l'organisateur et
définir une convention que nous sommes
en train de finaliser avec le ministère
de l'Intérieur et le ministère de la
Justice pour répartir les compétences de
chacun globalement les responsabilités
de chacun quelle est la responsabilité
du club organisateur quelle est la
responsabilité de l'ordre public et
cette responsabilité là pour faire vite
le stade c'est le club l'extérieur du
stade c'est l'ordre public ça c'est
assez clair elle se décline tout au long
de la saison c'est-à-dire que finalement
la saison elle se prépare en début de
saison on regarde les matchs qui vont se
dérouler sur la saison pour identifier
les matchs à risque et puis après peu de
temps avant les matchs un mois 15 jours
8 jours avant les matchs le l'analyse du
niveau de risque est affinée et puis
après le match se déroule et un
débriefing du match est fait alors
pardon pour cette introduction un peu
longue mais c'est pour répondre à votre
question donc finalement avant match il
y a un dispositif d'encadrement ou
d'interdiction des supporters en
déplacement là il y a une une une double
possibilité juridique la première c'est
une interdiction pure et simple de
déplacement ça c'est le ministère le
ministre de l'Intérieur lui-même qui
prend un arrêté
d'interdiction de déplacement des
supporters parisiens à Marseille par
exemple ou Marseille à Paris et c'est le
déplacement des supporters qui est
purement et simplement interdit après
vous avez des mesures
d'encadrement des supporters en
déplacement là ces mesures d'encadrement
c'est c'était l'objet de des supporters
lyonnais à Marseille où vous avez un
nombre de supporter qui est fixé par
l'ordre public local par la préfecture
locale et qui va définir finalement le
bon volume de supporter à à déplacer le
le volume qui est admissible au regard
des contraintes d'or public ça c'est oui
oui non mais ça c'est avant les matchs
et après sur la question des
interdictions je finis là-dessus sur la
question des interdictions derrière vous
avez en fonction des actes qui ont été
commis par des individus sur un match
qu'ils étaient interdits ou pas euh là
on parle de mesures individuelles ils
peuvent être interdits par pardon
judiciaairement par le juge qui prononce
une peine complémentaire d'interdiction
de stade suite à un phénomène de
violence ou alors par prévention par le
préfet lui-même qui par précaution pour
prévenir des risques ultérieurs va
prononcer des interdictions dites
administratives et en complément donc
vous avez interdiction judiciaire
interdiction administrative
et les clubs peuvent également prononcer
des interdictions commerciales de stade
c'est-à-dire au regard ils peuvent faire
leur leur leur
leur sécurité interne et considérer que
un un supporter qui s'est mal
comporté va être privé de d'achat de
Billet pendant un temps donné donc voilà
les trois niveaux d'interdiction
individuel le stade et collective en en
amant des matchs je sais pas
si j'is comprre
question que la question était de dire
est-ce que quelqu'un qui est interdit de
stade peut peut se rendre en déplacement
c'est
c'est alors non je je vais vous laisser
terminer vous pouvez compléter on va
devoir interrompre momentanément parce
que Madame la rapporteur a dû partir en
séance et elle revient juste après et il
faut absolument qu'elle soit là pour
maintenir par contre comment la question
est posée vous pouvez continuer donc
allez-y détailler par que ce qui nous
intéressait également c'était surtout
d'une interdiction d'un stade pourquoi
cette interdiction n'est pas pérénisée
sur tous les stades alors c'est c'est
c'est toute la toute la question de du
périmètre d'application des
interdictions de stade et même de
l'obligation de de de de pointage
c'està-dire que l'interdiction de stade
elle doit être assortie d'une
interdiction de pointage au commissariat
d'une d'une interdiction d'une
obligation de pointage pardon au
commissariat le temps des matchs de
l'équipe dans laquelle le lesffets de
violence ont été commis un supporter de
Lyon va être interdit de stade pour les
matchs de l'Olympique Lyonnais et comme
vous le dites c'est pas une interdiction
globale territorial de tous les matchs
de football sinon la la la personne en
question elle irait tous les soirs
pointter au commissariat parce qu'il y a
des matchs un peu tout le temps mais
c'est ça pose la question de
l'application de la règle par rapport à
ce qui a été prononcé et c'est c'est
pareil ça fait partie des préconisations
du rapport Bower et le ministère des
Sports travail sur ces questions là
comment lier par avec des dispositifs de
billetterie pour s'assurer que
l'interdit de stade ne rentre pas dans
le stade grâce au système de billetterie
et sécuriser la billetterie un peu plus
qu'elle ne l' par rapport à ça voilà
donc ça il y a des travaux et dans le
cadre de la de la loi sur sur les sur
les les JO il peut y avoir des
évolutions qui permettent de sécuriser
encore mieux l'application de ces
interdictions de
stade est-ce que l'un de vous veut
compléter moi j'ai rien à compléter si
ce n'est que philosophiquement c'est
vraiment un sujet à creuser moi je pense
que on va pas on va pas régler le
problème de violence dans le sport et
dans la société que grâce à ça mais il
faut qu'on durcisse le point sur les
interdictions stade c'est clé ce sont
toujours toujours les mêmes individus
qui cassent qui font des violences ou
qui sinon qui entraînent les autres
parce que il y a aussi des individus qui
sont très calmes dans la vie de tous les
jours et avec ce phénomène de masse mais
entraîné par certains ils se rendent
plus compte de ce qu'ils font ils
perdent la tête ils sont inconscients et
donc je pense que ces gens-là il faut
que les force de police il faut faut que
tout le monde s'y mette qu'on les
identifie mais qu'on les bannisse de
tous nos stades mais pas 2 ans pas 3 ans
pas 6 Ave et déjà je pense que les
choses vont aller mieux
voilà alors je n'ai pas la possibilité
de vous poser une autre
question c'est enregistré donc la la
réponse est enregistrée de toute façon
donc il faut qu'on attende un petit peu
que les collègues reviennent sont partis
voter également madame la
rapporteur donc la loi du 10 mai 2016
renforçant le dialogue avec avec les
supporters et la lutte contre le
légalisme a prévu la désignation par les
clubs de référents supporters quel bilan
dressez-vous de ce dispositif est-il
bien impliqué dans le monde du foot dans
le vadmcom sur les référents SUPPORTERS
FOOTBALL édité par l'INS LFP en novembre
2022 la ministre des Sports estime que
les référents supporters sont désormais
pleinement intégrés dans le paysage
sportif et ont su assurer l'ensemble des
missions qui leur sont assignées par
z-vous ce constat plus largement
pouvez-vous nous présenter le dispositif
permettant d'assurer au cours de chaque
match la prévention des
incidents alors il y a deux questions en
une c'est le le la question des
référents supporters c'est effectivement
un dispositif qui a été prévu comme vous
l'avez rappelé par par la loi de 2016 et
en lien avec l'instance nationale du
supporterisme piloté par le ministère
des sports on a effectivement contribué
à la mise en place des référents
supporters dans chacun des clubs c'estàd
que que chaque club devait désigner euh
une personne en charge de faire le lien
entre le club et les groupes de
supporters he c'est c'est le rôle du
référent supporter c'est pas d'être un
supporter euh en lien direct avec le
club mais bien d'avoir une interface
entre le club et les les équipes de
sécurité notamment et les groupes de
supporters pour finalement échanger des
informations pour aider à une meilleure
préparation des matchs essayer
d'anticiper euh les besoins des
supporters d'un côté et les besoins de
sécurité de l'autre c'est pour ça que
les référents supporters sont un
interlocuteur privilégié des directeurs
de sécurité des clubs mais aussi euh des
directeurs départemental de la sécurité
publique euh c'est un dispositif qui est
animé euh par des personnes de la Ligue
il y a aujourd'hui deux salariés à temps
plein qui gèrent ces questionslà une
personne avait été recrutée pour
l'occasion en 2016 et elle a été
renforcé depuis l'année dernière et on
est effectivement euh impliqué parce
qu'on pense que c'est une un dispositif
qui est efficace puisqu'il privilégie le
dialogue mais pas que le dialogue
surtout l'échange d'information pour
essayer encore une fois de de
d'anticiper la préparation des matchs et
ce dispositif et ça fait le lien avec
votre deèe question en quoi il peut
prévenir des violences euh il il est il
est utile si les les les les les
demandes des supporters et les besoins
des forces de l'ordre ou les besoins des
supporters et les demandes des forces de
l'ordre dans dans n'importe quel sens
sont bien échangés et on a participé
également avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur à des à des tests dans
plusieurs clubs de référents police pour
que finalement le le référent supporter
est un interlocuteur au niveau de la
police qui puisse lui aussi faire le
lien avec avec les autorités publiques
locales donc le référent supporter oui
participe à une meilleure préparation
des matchs après euh en matière de
sécurité c'est pas la solution miracle
je peux pas vous répondre que c'est ce
dispositif qui va régler tous les
problèmes de sécurité dans les stat ça
peut aider à pacifier les relations en
amont et une meilleure préparation des
matchs pour prévenir des
incidents et en particulier comme la LFP
l'assure comment comment gérer la
formation des référents des
supporters on on les réunit on les
réunit au moins une fois par an
c'est-à-dire qu'au moins une fois par an
on a un séminaire dédié pour les
référents supporters comme on a au moins
une fois par an un séminaire qui est
dédié au
directeurs sûreté sécurité des clubs et
à ces occasions on échange sur les
bonnes pratiques on prévoit des
interventions extérieures et on essaie
de de les de les faire monter en
compétence pour qu'ils aient les les
outils nécessairire à l'accomplissement
de leur
mission et pour résumer donc quel rôle
joue le le référen supporter dans la
prévention et dans la répression des
comportements racistes ou homophobes
pendant les compétitions sportives en
particulier peut-il identifier les
personnes qui se rendent coupables de
tels agissements avant de transmettre
leur identité au procureur de la
République il peut y contribuer mais
c'est pas son rôle il peut y contribuer
mais c'est pas lui qui est chargé il est
pas chargé d'une mission de sécurité en
fait les le le le référent supporter il
ne se substitue pas au dispositifs de
sécurité privé ou public mise en place
par le club et les autorités il cherche
à le à le prévenir il peut aider à
l'identification des fauteurs de trouble
quand après match par exemple il y a des
des des images de vidéo protection
suffisamment précises pour identifier
les auteurs mais c'est pas lui qui peut
garantir la la la la pleine application
des des dispositifs de prévention c'est
un maillon parmi d'autres je pense que
c'est pour ça qu'on doit on doit creuser
le sujet au-delà du référence support
moi il y a un truc qui me tape sur le
système c'est les champs
homophobes on en a beaucoup on a des
satisfaite sur d'autres points sur les
champs homophobes on en a beaucoup
beaucoup le paroxisme c'est le le
paris-germain om de cette saison moi
j'ai mis 3 minutes à comprendre ce qu'il
disait ça faisait longtemps que j'étais
pas aussi mal à l'aise dans un stade j'y
étais je vais je vais pas j'étais au
stade ça fait très longtemps que j'étais
pas aussi mal à l'aise on a une
problématique derrière ça on on voulait
sanctionner individuellement mais ils
étaient quoi 7000 8000 10000 donc on
comprenait pas comment faire on s'est
dit on va sanctionner collectivement on
va punir des gens et finalement c'est
une discussion que j'ai eu quelques
jours après avec avec la ministre des
Sports je me demande si au-delà du
référent supporter on devrait pas
responsabiliser davantage les leaders de
ces groupes de supporters dans les
virages qui sont ceux qui lancent les
champs à un moment en tout cas c'est
quelque chose qu'on doit creuser parce
que ça on va pas on va pas s'en sortir
donc référence support c'est bien pour
la relation de confiance mais mais ça
c'est limite et je pense que maintenant
il faut qu'on passe un cadre et qu'on
arrive à responsabiliser aussi les
responsables des groupe ultra qui sont
finalement les leaders qui lancent les
champs parce qu'ils ont pas tous les
8000 gars subitement sont dit tiens on
va chanter ça non mais ça marche pas
comme ça donc c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
peut-être n en tout cas c'est la su qu'
qu'on brainstorm en ce moment à défut
d'être très efficace mais pour pour
rebondir sur ce que vient de dire
Vincent Labrune c'est dans la dans la
loi que vous citz il y avait le pendant
du dispositif côté club et référent
supporters côté association de
supporters avec la volonté de labelliser
les associations de supporters de sorte
que ça deviennent des interlocuteurs
crédibles aujourd'hui on discute nous
beaucoup avec l'Association nationale
des supporters qui représente des
groupes de supporters mais c'est pas
leur faire offense que de dire qu'il ne
représente pas tous les groupes de
supporters en France et il y a une une
question d'organisation et de
représentation des groupes de supporters
aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas tous
constitués en association et c'est pour
ça que c'est difficile de de de
aujourd'hui de les identifier et de
pouvoir comme le dit justement
Vincent trouver les les les responsables
de ceux qui lancent des des des pareil
champs une question de Stéphane bûchou
merci madame la Présidente sur cette
question justement des des champs
homophobes bon vous venez de de nous
expliquer tout ce que vous vous tentiez
pour oui oui enfin ouais pour pour pour
pour pour y mettre fin en tous les cas
le le brainstorming en en cours
euh vous disiez monsieur le Président
tout à l'heure effectivement c'est
euh le football est un reflet de la de
la société il y a de malheureusement de
l'homophobie dans notre société et pas
totalement
euh farfelu qu'il y en ait
malheureusement dans dans le dans le
football et dans le dans les stades moi
ce que je voulais savoir c'est au-delà
du brainstorming que vous avez que que
vous mettez en en œuvre
jusqu'où jusqu'où vous êtes prêt à aller
pour éradiquer ces champ homophobes pour
fréquenter les stades depuis très
longtemps euh j'ai moi j'en ai toujours
malheureusement j'en ai toujours connu
je je je je je voilà alors ça va de ça
va de malempie je je lors d'autres
auditions je je n'ai plus en tête qui
disait ça si c'est un illustre joueur
donc que je ne citerai pas ici qui
disait que lui considérait que les
choses se sont amélioré depuis quelques
années prenant des arguments que je
trouvais quelque peu fallacieux mais bon
peu importe mais c'est c'est vrai que
moi je note par exemple c'est un tout
petit exemple et c'est peut-être pas
c'est ni documenté ni documenté Paron ni
ni objectivé mais c'est vrai que lorsque
j'étais plus jeune la la la très
mauvaise habitude c'était que quand le
gardien dégageait il y avait un chant
que je ne évidemment je ne je ne
prononcerai pas
ici je note même si je vais de moins en
moins enfin moins au stade j'ai
l'impression que ça ça ne se dit plus ou
en tous les cas ça se dit moins bref je
ferme la parenthèse peut-être je me
trompe et et et mais voilà jusqu'où
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
aller que vous venez de faire sur votre
jeunesse vos souvenirs de stade je en
parla hier moi la première fois que j'ai
entendu une insulte de ma vie dans un
stade c'est à Orléan j'avais 7 ou 8 ans
en allant voir mon équipe de 2è division
c'était ça je comprenais pas donc je
ferme aussi la
parenthèse on est prêt à aller le plus
loin possible c'est même pas que ça
m'inupporte ça me rend fou donc voilà ça
me rend fou toutes les questions de
discrimination général m'inupporte les
questions liées à l'homophobie me
rendent fou donc dans un premier temps
déjà le protocole européen il est bien
fait faut qu'on arrête systématique
qu'on interrompe la rencontre faut qu'on
interrompe la rencontre ça me semble une
bonne mesure de marquer le coup j'ai pas
compris franchement au Parc des Princes
j'y reviens c'est moi qu'en parle c'est
même pas vous ça a duré quand même 10
minutes la plaisanterie pourquoi
l'arbitre l'avait pas fait finalement de
bonne fois il y a une telle tension un
tel enjeu une telle énergie tellement de
bruit je pense qu'il était concentré sur
son match il est pas infaillible c'est
pas lui qui qui a été qui failli c'est
peut-être plutôt les délégué au bord de
terrain qu'it pu dire peu importe moi je
suis pour l'interruption des rencontres
systématiques point 1 par contre je peux
pas être
pour l'interruption définitive des
rencontres de façon systématique pour
une raison très simple qui s'appelle un
principe de réalité c'est que vu
quasiment à chaque match il y a des
champs si à chaque match on arrête le
match de façon définitive on va plus
jamais les jouer les matchs donc il y
aura plus de sport c'est pas ça le but
faut pas qu'il gagne cela faut pas qu'il
nous tu le sport donc AR moi
philosophiquement je suis pour
l'interruption préventive du match on
l'interrompt une fois deux fois trois
fois par contre on arrête et là on tape
voilà je
sais après il y a ce qui se déroule en
match et sur les sur les discriminations
qu'elle soi homophobe ou raciste on a
trois piliers d'action c'est les trois
piliers que rappelait Vincent et on peut
effectivement détailler un tout petit
peu ce qu'on fait sur ces questions il y
a un premier pilier qui est la
sensibilisation en amont et où
effectivement on est on est assez
pionnier en la matière mais ça reste
très difficile on fait de la
sensibilisation au niveau des club ça
reste très difficile parce que euh on
est et je vous donnerai des éléments
après après l'audition mais on est à 48
ateliers dans 20 clubs différents ça
paraît une belle opération mais ça
demande beaucoup d'investissement pour
le moment parce qu'on le fait avec les
associations avec lesquelles on est
partenair SOS Homophobie Panam boys fout
ensemble au Val citoyen mais c'est lourd
long à organiser c'est un travail de
longue haleine et qui doit être
permanent il faut qu'on arrive à
développer ces dispositifs de
sensibilisation à plus grande échelle en
formant des formateurs pour essayer de
de d'expliquer aux gens en quoi
aujourd'hui l'homophobie c'est un délit
c'est grave c'est comme le RAC isme
c'est une discrimination qui est
inacceptable et c'est pas pour rire donc
là-dessus on est dans la droite ligne de
des instructions que nous donnent
Vincent on met en place ces ces
campagnes de sensibilisation on a une
action disciplinaire qui peut être
critiquable on peut toujours critiquer
la commission de discipline c'est pas
c'est pas le sujet je crois aujourd'hui
mais on a une action disciplinaire où
les champs sont sanctionnés les propos
racistes sont évidemment sanctionné
quand il y en a et forth heureusement il
y en a il y en a beaucoup moins et puis
la la troisème voix c'est les campagnes
de communication grand public parce que
on estime que étant la première
discipline sportive professionnelle en
France on a un devoir de
citoyenneté de de de et d'exemplarité
par rapport à ça alors on a été beaucoup
critiqué à tort à nos yeux sur les
opération de de de de de numéro
arc-en-ciel l'année dernière parce qu'on
considère que cinq joueurs n'ont pas
porté le maillot moi j'aurais tendance à
retenir à la Ligue on a plutôt tendance
à retenir qu'il y en a 751 sur les 750 6
joueurs qui étent inscrit sur la sur les
feuilles de match de cette dernière
journée qui l'ont porté sauf qu'on doit
quand même regarder les choses et on le
fait avec nos associations et peut-être
vous avez vu que ça fait partie des
débats qui ont été relayés dans la
presse ces dernières semaines
aujourd'hui on se pose la question de
savoir de quelle manière on doit
continuer la question n'est pas de
savoir si on va arrêter de faire des
campagnes de de de de de promotion de la
lutte contre les discriminations mais
nos associations nous disent elles-mêm
qu'à un moment donné défendre la cause
c'est noble mais il faut pas que en
défendant la cause on crée un buzz
négatif qui pénalise finalement le
message que l'on veut porter et
aujourd'hui le message que l'on porte
pour certains pas pour tout le monde
pour certains manque de clarté et la
distinction entre lutter contre
l'homophobie et faire la promotion de
l'homosexualité la frontière est tenue
et aujourd'hui nous évidemment il ne
s'agit pas de faire la promotion de
l'homosexualité c'est pas notre boulot
par contre lutter contre le le le
l'homophobie ça l'IT et donc on réfléchi
à un dispositif qui pourrait être plus
clair dans la communication et donc on a
bien ces trois voies
euh
sensibilisation discipline ou juridique
quand il y a des actes de racisme ou de
ou homophobe qui sont prononcer on peut
se constituer partie civile ou saisir le
le le le procureur de la République
quand il y a des des des faits qui sont
de cette nature de nature
discriminatoire et puis après des des
campagnes de communication donc là on
aura euh sur la J25 une campagne dédiée
sur la lutte contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme en partenariat avec la
Licra avec laquelle on on travaille
depuis
euh depuis longtemps je dirais depuis
les années 20056 euh et avec lesquels on
bâtit avec laquelle on bâtit une journée
dédiée avec une opération spécifique et
sur la dernière journée de championnat
de Ligue 1 et de Ligue 2 on aura encore
une campagne de lutte contre contre
l'homophobie on ne s'arrêtera pas je
observe juste et c'est pas pour euh
fondfaroné qu'on est la seule Ligue à
faire ces campagnes là c'estàd qu'on
peut nous critiquer sur les numéro
arc-en-ciel nous dire on se pose des
questions on s'interroge de savoir quel
est le bon outil de comm j'observe juste
qu'on est les seuls à le faire en France
et dans le monde
voilà merci hein pour ces pour ces
éléments moi ça m'amène je vousi pas
demandé la permission de reprendre la
parole madame la Présidente pardon ça
m'amène plusieurs observations
euh la première c'est en réaction à à ce
que vous avez dit Monsieur la
brune vous avez dit
euh en fait moi je suis pour la l'arrêt
systématique des matchs mais on peut pas
les arrêter définitivement parce qu'en
fait les matchs et je partage il faut
les jouer bon
euh je fais une petite parenthèse
l'audition elle est publique
elle est diffusée sur le site de
l'Assemblée
nationale je alors je un peu de sport
fiction ou d'audition fiction j'en sais
rien moi je me mets à la place d'un
supporter qui pour qui c'est naturel
d'avoir des champ homophobe dans un
stade il vous entend je pas une critique
hein il vous entend il dit bon ben ok je
vais continuer parce que de toute façon
je sais que le match va reprendre non
non
mais alors j'ai peut-être mal
compris match au premier champ et au 2è
ou au 3è on l'interrom
définitivement non non attention c'est
pas ce que j'ai
dit donc j'ai mal compris mais je pense
que la précision est
utile dans ce que dans ce que vous dites
c'est important parce que
c'est une discussion qu'il faut avoir
avec les supporters eux-mêmes et et les
campagnes de sensibilisation on les mène
auprès des joueurs auprès des dirigeants
de club mais aussi auprès des supporters
de club dire que quand on propose un
club club d'aller sur place on rencontre
les joueurs les dirigeants mais aussi
les groupes de supporters qui veulent
bien participer notre objectif il est
simple c'est juste de faire comprendre
que les propos tenus euh n'ont pas lieu
d'être dans un stade tout simplement et
que les les les supporters qui sont très
à cheval sur leur liberté c'est pardon
c'est légitime sur tout un tas de
principes républiquain il faudrait qu'il
comprennent que ces champs-là sont
purement et simplement horduriers et non
pas leur place dans les stades et puis
c'est quand même un peu ringard quoi
c'estd que eux qui sont passés pour des
révolutionnaires la main sur le cœur il
faudrait qu'ils comprennent qu'ils sont
complètement à côté de la plaque et à
côté de la société dans laquelle ils
évoluent et c'est ces messages là qu'on
essaie de faire passer pour qu'ils
comprennent d'euxmême et vous l'avez dit
vous-même on entend moins le fameux
champ au dégagement des des des des des
des gardiens mais il y a il y a encore
de l'homophobie dans l'estad il s'agit
pas pour nous de nier le
phénomène alors du coup euh merci de ces
précisions moi ça m'amène
d'autres d'autres observations si ah
j'avais pas le droit ah bon
euh en
fait je je mets ça sur le j'ess al
toutes choses égal par ailleurs je pense
qu'on est un certain nombre dans cette
salle à avoir connu
l'ouiganisme au-delà la au-delà de la
Manche euh les Anglais ont réussi à y
mettre fin
avec une méthodologie qui leur est
propre donc ma question vous voyez
arriver avec mes gros sabots est-ce que
est-ce que cette méthodologie alors qui
est pas forcément à la main de la Ligue
est-ce que cette méthodologie je vais
aller au bout comme ça vous répondrez en
en bloc est-ce que cette méthodologie on
peut imaginer qu'elle puisse être
applicable au fait dont on est en train
de parler pour justement mettre fin à
ses à ses comportements et à ses champs
homophobes ça c'est pour la question et
puis deux observations on a eu
l'occasion d'uditionner Lilian
turam avec qui on a eu des échanges
vraiment passionnants et sur sa manière
qui lui est vraiment propre
d'appréhender justement les questions
alors plus de racisme que d'homophobie
mais au travers de sa fondation et en
fait moi ce que j'ai trouvé
particulièrement intéressant dans les
échanges qu'on a eu avec avec lui c'est
qu'en fait il nous expliquait moi
j'avais pas c'est peut-être naïf de ma
part mais moi j'avais pas forcément
je n'avais pas forcément conscience et
il m'en a fait prendre conscience qu'au
fond celles et ceux qui se rendent
coupable de ces champs homophobes ou de
ces champs
racistes ne savent peut-être même pas ce
qu'est le racisme et ce qu'est
l'homophobie et que selon lui et je ne
voudrais pas trahir ses propos il y a un
vrai travail en profondeur
d'acculturation au vivre ensemble et
donc à ces questions d'homophobie et de
racisme donc ma question c'est est-ce
que la Ligue a pris attache avec la
fondation de l'îenturam pour pour sur
parce que là on est vraiment sur un
temps long et on est vraiment sur un un
aspect éducatif et pédagogique et puis
3è 3è
question que pensez-vous
de plus impliquer les joueurs puisque
tout à l'heure monsieur le Président
vous fais vous faisiez référence à
l'arbitre euh on a eu l'occasion
d'auditionner une association qui
s'appelle rouge direct je sais pas si
vous si vous connaissez cette
association et
eux plaident pour que des joueurs
s'impliquent et que à l'instar de
l'arbitre qui bah entend alors certes il
est concentré mais enfin si ça dure 10
minutes il peut quand même entendre
puisse dire à un moment euh moi j'arrête
de jouer dans ces conditions et je
termine je suis pas trop long déjà trop
long mais je le suis je le sais non et
je termine parce que j'aié j'ai posé
cette question là lenturam et alors lui
il était en en total ENF en total on
avait un désaccord parce qu'il me dit en
fait le problème monsieur le député
c'est que les joueurs le feront pas on
avait pris l'exemple de Kylian Mbappé
parce que c'est parce que c'est Kylian
Mbappé mais ça pourrait être tous les
autres mais en fait ils le feront pas
parce que au fond ils n'ont pas
forcément conscience justement de ce
qu'est l'homophobie et de ce qui'est le
racisme donc ils ont ils ne vont pas
forcément avoir le réflexe de dire moi
j'arrête de jouer dans ces conditions
voilà je voulais avoir
votre juste compléter la question de mon
collègue Stéphane bûchou quand on dit il
revient à l'arbitre de d'interrompre le
match d'abord que faire si l'arbitre ne
s'en préoccupe pas qu'il a qu' n pas la
volonté d'interrompre le match est-ce
que vous avez des consignes et et
pourquoi j'ai envie de dire le protocole
d'interruption de match n'est jamais
appliqué je fais une toute petite
parenthèse avant qu'Arn réponde plus
dans le détail pour par rapport à ce que
vous dire sur sur Lilian et sa fondation
et la culturation de certains on va
évidemment faire le maximum mais je fais
partie des moi je suis un citoyen je
suis républicain ça commence au foyer et
à l'école alors le foot on va faire
notre part plus que de raisons mais on
va pas non plus se substituer au foyer
et et à l'école alors pour répondre à
votre série de questions et puis à la
vutre également sur le modèle
anglais je dirais qu'aujourd'hui le le
le le si on doit synthétiser puisqueon
on a pas l'après-midi pour en parler le
modèle anglais repose sur un dispositif
qui est simple c'est l'identification
des fauteurs de trouble et leur
interdiction ils sont sur des sanctions
individuelles individuelles ils oui
c'est l'État qui euh qui euh qui est en
capacité d'identifier les les les les
les policiers sont dans les tribunes il
ils identifient les fauteurs de troubl
il les interdisent purement et
simplement sur des durées extrêmement
longues de stade donc on n'est pas du
tout dans un dispositif
comme le nôtre où l'État intervient il
s'agit pas ici de taper sur l'état loin
de là on est on essaie de travailler de
concert parce qu'on considère que la la
sécurité c'est l'affaire de tous il
s'agit pas d'aller critiquer le le le
copain néanmoins on observe quand même
que il y a il y a un trou dans la
raquette entre l'interpellation
l'identification d'individu et les
suites judiciaire on travaille beaucoup
avec le ministère de la Justice
maintenant pour essayer de faire en
sorte que l'information descendre dans
les parquets pour que lesffits de
violence dans les stades soient traités
avec une plus grande sévérité qu'elle ne
l'ai aujourd'hui on a deux exemples sur
si on a le temps sur Nice Marseille et
Nice lance c'est assez assez
symptomatique de de d'un dossier qui
avait été traité d'effets similaires de
de de salu naasie donc extrêmement grave
dans le dans le stade relayé par la
plateforme de signalement qu'on a avec
laalcra et les réseaux dans le premier
cas le supporter je veux pas dire de
conneries ou je je vous dirai
précisément les les les il a été puni
d'une peine de prison d'un an
d'emprisonnement avec surc dans le deuxè
cas il a eu 500 € d'amende et notre
constitution de partie civile n'a pas
été admise on a écrit au procureur pour
dire qu'on qu'on trouvait ça un peu
singulier il nous a répondu comme il
doit le faire en disant pour qui vous
prenez pour m'écrire mais néanmoins deux
cas strictement identiques au même
endroit sont pas traités de la même
manière donc aujourd'hui les progrès
qu'on a à faire sont des progrès
collectifs pour que le le le le le le
principe des tri al pardon mais c'est
identification interpellation
interdiction il s'applique
individuellement voilà et c'est ce qui
nous différenci du modèle anglais donc
très très rapidement au-delà de
l'augmentation du prix des places qu'on
cite beaucoup mais c'est c'est c'est
surtout ce ce phénomain là de de de
prise en compte par par le gouvernement
sur Lilian turam il a raison évidemment
qu'il faut faire de la formation et de
la sensibilisation d'ailleurs on a
évolué nous dans nos dans nos journées
de sensibilisation on implique l'UNFP
maintenant euh puisque vous le savez
l'UNFP fait partie du conseil
d'administration de la Ligue et comme
l'a dit vcent on est très attaché au
fait de travailler avec l'ensemble des
familles qui composent le le conseil
d'administration de la Ligue donc l'UNFP
est impliqué dans nos séances de
sensibilisation pour porter un discours
euh aux joueurs via les délégués euh
régionaux et via les référents NFP dans
chacun des vestiaires pour que le
message soit passé et on met au même
plan toutes les discriminations
c'est-à-dire qu'avant on parler de lutte
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme et
de lutte contre l'homophobie maintenant
on parle de lutte contre les
discriminations et le racisme et
l'homophobie est au même plan et traité
de la même manière dans les mêmes
journées de sensibilisation pour que les
joueurs comprennent ou nos
interlocuteurs comprennent du niveau de
gravité de la discrimination en tant que
telle par contre comme vous l'a dit
Lilian Tura mais sans trahir ses propos
je comprends bien c'est un c'est un
c'est un projet de long terme je vous ai
dit que euh on s'était lancé dans ces
campagnes de
sensibilisation mais que c'était lourd
que toutes les énergies étaient bonne à
prendre et que dans les travaux euh que
l'on mène avec le ministère des sports
on est en train de regarder enfin le
ministère des Sports s'interroge sur le
fait de pouvoir labéiser des
associations qui seraient en capacité de
mener euh ces campagnes de
sensibilisation à tous les niveaux pas
qu'au niveau du football pro comme l'a
dit Vincent c'est au niveau aussi du du
football amateur de tous les sports et
autres pour que finalement la formation
soit plus efficace et que les gens
comprennent effectivement ce qu'ils
disent et que ils prenaient l'exemple de
il faut expliquer aux joueurs ce qu'est
de porter un maillot avec un numéro
arc-en-ciel c'est vrai que il a raison
le le les clubs sont là pour le faire et
encore une fois on peut se réjouir que
l'ensemble des joueurs les porter c'est
pas parce qu'il y a cinq joueurs qui
l'ont pas porté qu'on doit euh tirer à
boulet rouge sur cette OP opération au
contraire il y a desouurs qui l'ont fa
qui qui qui l'ont fait donc c'est très
positif euh et puis après pour pour
répondre à la question de madame la
Présidente sur que faire si l'arbitre
n'est pas comme l'a dit Vincent en
capacité 2 c'est effectivement moi je
les joueurs sur des sur des sur des
matchs quand il y a des fait de racisme
parfois les joueurs ont été interpeler
directement la personne qui les avait
insulté parce qu'il l'avait entendu il
avait eu autre mais il faut pas compter
euh trop sur les acteurs de terrain pour
pour euh pour pouvoir entendre ce qui se
dit dans un stade enfin on a tous été
dans un stade j'imagine vous voyez bien
que la perception d'un champ elle est
euh elle est euh elle est parfois
difficile et puis heureusement
heureusement le cas de PSG Marseille est
assez rare dans sa durée en fait ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a encore
des champs homophobes c'est vrai mais
sur des durées assez courtes et
finalement le champ s'est déjà arrêté
quand il est il est temps euh
d'interrompre le match par contre le
protocole FIFA est effectivement clair
si les chances sont continues l'arbitre
peut interrompre le match et
généralement il y a une prise de
conscience assez assez rapide à la
première ou à la deuxème
interruption je voudrais revenir sur
l'audition de de Pierre barartelémi
membre du Bureau de l'Association
nationale des supporters il a critiqué
le fonctionnement des commissions de
discipline de la LFP et de la FFF selon
lui les commissions de discipline
prennent des désormais la décision
d'épargner les clubs et de sanctionner
les supporters en fermant toute la
tribune cela signifie qu'en cas de
mauvais comportement de quelques
personnes par exemple en cas de champ
raciste tous les supporters sont
sanctionnés ces sanctions collectives
constituent un détournement grave de la
mission disciplinaire des commissions et
repose sur des présomptions
paternalistes selon lesquelles les
supportant les supporters sont inaptes à
vivre en collectivité qu'ils sont
stupides et dépourvu d'intelligence
collective et de culture que vous
inspirent ces propos qui font font écho
au constat formulé en novembre 2022 par
la société AB conseil qui préconise
plutôt une meilleure individualisation
des
sanctions ça rejoint ce qu'on a dit
précédemment c'est la sanction
collective c'est pas une fin en soi et
ça ne suffit pas à régler l'ensemble des
problèmes après supprimer les sanctions
collectives comme le propose pierre
belémi qu'on connaît bien qu'on apprécie
par ailleurs pour passer de de
nombreuses réunions ensemble donc on
connaît par cœur ces ces ces arguments
ça n'est pas non plus une une solution
et effectivement la commission de
discipline elle ne peut faire que ça la
commission discipline comme l'a dit
Vincent tout à l'heure elle n'a pas de
pouvoir de police elle ne peut pas sauf
si c'est un licencié aller sanctionner
un individu un individu de façon isolée
donc elle elle elle procède à des
sanctions collectives j'observe juste la
différence entre ce que dit Pierre
bartelémi et de
l'autre les appel aux sanctions
extrêmement fermes qui sont formulées
par tout notre environnement social
économique médiatique politique quand il
y a des incidents dans les stades qui
appelle à à des des hclos des retraits
de point des fermetures de tribunes
voilà donc effectivement oui on ferme
des tribune on l'assume on met des
matchs à hclos on l'assume on on ferme
des on enlève des points parfois
rarement quand c'est des faits
extrêmement grave mais on ne peut rien
faire d'autre que ça et c'est à et et et
c'est encore une fois pas balancer la
patate chaude à l'état surtout pas mais
les sanctions individuelles c'est du
ressort de la justice et pas de pas de
notre fait donc pierre belémi son
interrogation faut la la la transmettre
au au Garde des saut que vous voyez
devain je
crois l'éducation entre guillemets
apportter à à nos supporters on va le
faire et c'est un travail de longaline
et c'est un travail qui qui est
passionnant mais il y a malheureusement
un truc qu'on pourra pas faire c'est
arrêter la bêtise humaine dans le monde
en France sauf à ce qu'on trouve une
baguette magique qu'on a pas encore donc
c'est un dossier qui est très compliqué
les sanctions collectives ça peut
sembler injuste mais il faut passer par
là pour que tout le monde comprenne mais
il faut absolument qu'on effectivement
qu'on les qu'on rajoute par-dessus des
sanctions individuelles et ça c'est pas
on aimerait bien mais pour l'instant
c'est pas de notre
sort et néanmoins comment estimez-vous
que ces sanctions individuelles est-ce
que vous pensez qu'il y a des failles
dans le dans le système et quelle
peut-être proposition vous pourriez nous
apporter à cette commission d'enquête
alors euh
oui la
la la enfin on l'a dit tout à l'heure en
propos introductif il y a trois natures
de de d'interdiction interdiction
administrative judiciire ou commerciale
le le le les clubs prononcent des
interdictions commerciales mais c'est
pas ça qui est dissuasif en fait la la
dissuasion quand quand on s'adresse à
des gens particulièrement violents c'est
pas leur dire au fait tu pourras pas
acheter de billet il va en acheter un
autre avec son copain c'est pas ça qui
est dissuasif c'est des c'est des
sanctions pénales qui sont dissuasives
puisqu'on parle de phénomène de violence
particulièrement grave donc quelqu'un
qui fait un salut nazi dans un stade je
je suis désolé mais la la sur Nice
Marseille on était euh satisfait de la
procédure on s'est dit tiens voilà ça
marche il y a de l'espoir euh grâce à un
signalement de la Licra par la
plateforme qu'on avait on a pu
identifier
avec le le les personnes chargées de
l'instruction sur place où était la
personne dans le stade avec les plans du
stade la personne a pu être identifiée
et elle a un an de prison avec surcil je
dis pas que c'est c'est ça me semble
être une une sanction dissuasive 500 €
euh sur le même fait oui et et et et je
je pense que la
la réponse à votre question est dans mon
exemple des deux faits sans sans aller
plus loin pour ne pas
accabler sur les sanctions individuelles
hein je
pas non
tu non je ça me fait enfin je ça m'amène
une réaction ce que ce que vous êtes en
train de dire parce que bon moi
j'entends euh j'entends j'entends
parfaitement ce que vous dites je bon je
peux vous rejoindre sur un sur un
certain nombre d'éléments sur la
différenci des peines qu'on soit à Nice
ou qu'on soit à 200 km c'est
l'individualisation des peines c'est
donc là c'est c'est je dis pas que c'est
ce que vous avez dit mais
c'est ah les
deuxis pardon autant pour moi
alors c'était une illustration je vis
pas qu'on enfin tout no raison tout
notre politique n'est pas bâtie sur sur
ce sur ce simple exemple c'est juste que
aujourd'hui pour répondre à à madame la
Présidente à l'exemple de de Pierre
barelémi la commission de discipline oui
elle ferme des tribunes oui elle
sanctionne mais elle elle comme comme
tout organe disciplinaire elle prend en
considération ce que les clubs amènent
et ce que les clubs font aujourd'hui les
clubs lorsqu'ils identifient des des des
des fauteurs de troubles pour que ce
soit pour des phénomènes de violence ou
ce qu'il y a de très fréquent des des
des craquages de fumigène mais les clubs
portent plaines contre les les ces
individus et la commission de discipline
elle prend en compte ces plaintes
nominative c'està-dire qu'il s'agit pas
de dire tiens je vais porter pleinte
contre X parce qu'il y a eu 20 fumigènes
dans mon stade non faut que les stadiers
a identifié les personnes qui portent
plaines et que qui derrière il y a des
suites judiciaires la la la la réalité
c'est que les suites judiciaires on en a
pas connaissance euh c'est assez peu
suivi donc vous avez des clubs qui font
leur boulot qui identifient les
personnes qui portent plainte et
derrière der des suites qui sont pas
forcément fait je vais vous donner des
chiffres que encore une fois je pourrais
vous vous remettre mais en Ligue 1 sur
la saison dernière il y a eu 153
plaintes nominatives déposées par les
clubs 57 par les clubs de Ligue 1 et 57
en Ligue 2 130 interdictions
commerciales de de de stade par les
clubs donc les clubs font leur boulot et
quand vous parliez de proposition il y a
un élément qui a
été apporté par une modification
législative de de l'année dernière c'est
les amendes forfaitaires délictuelles
notamment pour les l'introduction de
d'engins pyrotechnique
ù les les les amendes forfaitaires
délictuelles pour des faits de violence
euh enfin pas grave peuvent être une
solution dissuasive puisqu'elles sont
elles peuvent être prononcées tout de
suite et il vaut mieux avoir 500 €
d'amende forfaitaire délictuelle que
d'attendre 2 ans avant d'avoir un
dossier qui soit classé par un juge
voilà donc on on n'est pas pour tout
doit arriver chez le juge et voilà mais
il peut y avoir des solutions celle-ci
en est une il faut on n pas assez de
recul pour en mesurer l'efficacité mais
il faudra peut-être attendre un moment
pour voir si c'est réellement
efficace la loi du 19 mai 2023 relative
aux Jeux olympiques et paralympiqu a
prévu que tout spectateur d'une
manifestation sportive devrait désormais
présenter un titre d'accès un décret au
Conseil d'État doit fixer les seuils de
spectateurs au-delà desquels les
organisateurs prévoient des titres
d'accès nominatif dématérialisés et
infalsifiable parti participez-vous
pardon à des échanges sur la fixation de
ces seuils comment devrait-il être fixé
et la large mise en œuvre d'une
billetterie nominative pourrait-elle
permettre de rééquilibrer les sanctions
collectives et les sanctions
individuelles grâce à une meilleure
identification en amont des personnes
responsables de violence alors oui on
participe aux travaux nous on a une une
une phrase très simple à la lig c'est
qu'on considère que la sécurité la
billetterie est le premier outil de
sécurisation d'un match c'est le premier
outil de sécurisation d'un match donc
oui évidemment quand le dispositif a été
porté dans la dans la loi à laquelle
vous faites référence le ministère des
Sports a mis en place un groupe de
travail pour participer à la rédaction
de ce décret à la définition des seuils
avoir les modalités d'application et les
travaux sont en cours pour aboutir Fred
tu nous envoyé un un mail encore
aujourd'hui pour faire état de ces
travaux ça me permet de te te passer la
parole mais oui on y participe et
oui donc effectivement il y a un groupe
de travail pour définir parce que le le
la loi donne une possibilité et
effectivement un décret sortira pour
définir les types de manifestations
sportives qui sont concernés parce que
l'esprit de la loi et du législateur
c'était de pas concerner l'ensemble des
matchs ou des matchs de dire de
championnat domestique qui a priori ne
relève pas de difficulté ou qui n'ont
pas de problème de fraude puisque c'est
la notion de fraude qui a été retenue et
donc effectivement c'est plutôt des
grands matchs àorté internationale et
qui effectivement peuvent être poser des
soucis en terme de de supporterisme donc
effectivement le décret qui qui va être
défini doit poser des seuils qui
permettent effectivement de concerner
ces seules ces seules enceintes
sportives ces seules compétition et pas
effectivement l'ensemble des matchs où
il y a pas forcément lieu de passer sur
un système de billetterie dématérialisé
infalsifiable al donc on par de la la
billetterie donc en particulier la
billetterie nominative permet-elle
permettrait-elle d'améliorer le
dispositif d'interdicition commerciale
de stade le rapport d'AB conseil juge ce
dispositif ni uniforme ni toujours
efficace d'abord en raison des
difficultés d'identification des
spectateurs à l'entrée du stade comment
la LFP envisage-t-elle d'aider les clubs
afin d'améliorer l'identification à
l'entrée des stad alors
la la la billeterie nominative c'est un
un mot qui qui qui cache des choses
complexes un point de vue opérationnel
quand on parle de billetterie nominative
c'est vous commandez un billet sur
Internet on vous demande votre prénom
votre nom puis vous achetez votre billet
vous vous rendez au spectacle
généralement dans tous les spectacles
auquels vous allez jamais personne va
contrôler votre nom et votre prénom à
l'entrée du stade une billetterie
nominative sécuridé ça veut dire que en
amant il faut que vous mettiez sur place
un dispositif opérationnel où vous avez
un rapprochement documentaire d'identité
à l'entrée de l'enceinte et ça c'est un
dispositif qui est d'un point de vue
opérationnel extrêmement lourd qui
juridiquement n'est pas si évident à
mettre en place parce que quand on parle
de rapprochement documentaire ou de
contrôle d'identité c'est qui le fait
qui l'opère est-ce que c'est c'est un
agent de la force publique ou un agent
de sécurité privée là si c'est un agent
de sécurité privée bah il fait un
rapprochement documentaire d'identité
sans que se sans et vous lui présentez
ce que vous voulez un P Navigo une carte
de piscine ou donc la la la la
billetterie sécurisée et nominative oui
c'est un vrai euh c'est un vrai axe de
progrès mais qui
passera par un une vérification de
l'identité du porteur de billets à
l'entrée du stade et comme le disait
Frédéric c'est tout l'objet des travaux
qui sont menés actuellement pour savoir
à partir de quel moment ou sur quel
tribune ou sur quel stade ou sur quel
match il faut des des dispositifs comme
cela extrêmement sécurisés et bien
évidemment que ça améliorer les choses
ah oui faut appeler un chat un chat faut
faut faut tendre vers
ça ouais toujours dans le prolongement
de
nos de nos échanges à vous entendre en
fait on est euh on on tend quand même
essayons d'être optimiste ça fait du
bien de temps en temps
oui on va on va s'y associer non plus
sérieusement
euh est-ce que est-ce que vous alors je
sais pas si vous pourrez me répondre ou
quelle réponse vous allez me faire mais
euh moi j'ai quand même le sentiment que
euh alors il y a une à vous entendre il
y a une véritable volonté de de
d'amélioration euh et au travers de
toutes les actions que vous mettez en
œuvre
bon on espère vraiment que que qu'on va
y
parvenir au-delà de ça euh est-ce que
les clubs au fond euh vont vont au bout
enfin moi je me suis souvent poser cette
question et je continue à me la poser je
vais je vais euh je vais vous donner un
ou deux exemples euh il m'arrive
effectivement d'aller au stade il
m'arrive aussi de regarder les matchs à
la télévision je je suis je je suis
toujours effaré lorsque je vois certains
supporters sortir des fumigènes euh dans
les tribune au bout d'un quart d'heure
20 minutes enfin peu importe
comment comment est-ce qu'on enfin
comment c'est possible comment c'est
possible aujourd'hui en
2023 que que compte tenu des des
contrôles qui il y a enfin alors est-ce
qu'il y a alors je sais pas si vous
pourrez répondre à cette question mais
c'est aussi de la réflexion à VO haute
est-ce qu'il y a une complicité de de
certains stadié dans dans dans dans
certaines dans certaines enceintes enfin
vraiment je je me pose la question et
quelles sont là aussi lorsque ça
arrive il se passe quoi au sein du club
est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment une une enquête est-ce que les
gens sont
identifiés ça c'est la première question
la seconde
question il y a à mon sens un petit
paradoxe dans ce que vous disiez
monsieur Rouger Rouger Rougier Rouger
pardon vous disiez tout à l'heure sur la
sanction commerciale bah c'est pas très
efficace et vous avez raison parce que
celui qui qui bénéf enfin qui à qui on
applique une interdiction de de de place
il va en acheter une avec le petit
copain or tout à l'heure sauireur de ma
part vous disez dans les sanctions il y
avait eu 157 157 interdictions
commerciales donc au fond est-ce que
est-ce que ça ça du sens et je reviens
sur mon premier point qui est le rôle
des clubs enfin moi je crois vraiment
qu'il y a il y a un une mécanique à
trouver entre les clubs entre enfin les
clubs la Ligue et le ministère et je je
pour illustrer ça
euh je je je partage que vous disiez
monsieur Labrune tout à l'heure quand
vous dites dans une tribune il y a pas
5000 débiles qui euh qui chante enfin il
peut y avoir 5000 débiles qui chantent
des propos homophobes mais il y en a pas
5000 qui croient réellement à ce qu'ils
disent et c'est effectivement lancé par
ce qu'on appelle un capot
généralement et moi là encore à l'instar
des des fumigènes comment se fait-il que
ces gens-là qui sont quand même assez
facilement identifiables ne soi jamais
sanction enfin ne soit jamais ne soit
que très rarement sanctionné et qu'on
continue à aller voir dans les stades
lancer les champs euh homophobe ou pas
homophobe mais à partir du moment où il
y a eu des champs homophobes bah c'est
stop quoi et c'est cette moi je crois
que c'est cette fermeté aussi dont on a
besoin pour que aussi des familles qui
ont qui ont peut-être un peu déserter
les stades puissent tranquillement
revenir voir un match de
foot dans les enceintes qu'elle
préfère le député avant de donner la
parole à qui sera bien plus précis que
moi philosophiquement faut séparer les
deux sujets d'une part la lutte contre
les discriminations je crois qui est
prioritaire et deuxièmement les le sujet
du filmg qui est prière aussi mais qui
est moins grave de mon point de vue dans
l'esprit même si ça peut causer des
blessures soyez certain pour vous
répondre qu'il y a un vrai change en
tout cas on essaie d'inculquer un
changement de mentalité au club et que
les clubs sont avec nous quand on dit
que les clubs sont unis derrière la
Ligue derrière un projet commun on a le
sentiment que les clubs sont
parfaitement conscient sur la lutte
contre toute forme de discrimination
l'homophobie le racisme et qui jou je
vais vous donner un exemple sur
l'homophobie l' po héros qui en plus de
l'opération qu'on fait fait fait un
maillot spécial rose pour le truc donc
on voit que ça évolue c'est des temps
donc j'ai le sentiment je suis peut-être
naïf mais j'ai vraiment le sentiment que
ça avance plutôt dans le bon sens ça
c'est pour toute cette partie lutte
contre l'excrimation pour la partie
fumigène je l'ai bien vécu j'ai été
président Olympique de Marseille pendant
6 ans évidemment qui a des complicités
internes notamment de de de stadiers qui
sont des de sociétés extérieures et euh
est-ce qu'on les sanctionne en tant que
club rarement est-ce que la Ligue les
sanctionne non mais est-ce qu'on
sanctionne les les craquage de fumichè
oui c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure
cl non mais les clubs si c'est ce qu'ils
font c'est ce qu'on vous a tout à
l'heure la commission de discipline
prend en compte la collaboration des
clubs et donc sur les dossiers de
craquage de fumigène
si le club vient avec le nom avec un
certain nombre de coupables la sanction
notamment pour le club en terme d'amende
est bien moindre donc on progresse un
petit peu
encore sur votre exemple effectivement
les fumigènes c'est pas forcément notre
sujet on se déplace un peu mais dans de
la commission tous les cas j'entends
mais juste pour bien comprendre vous
disiez effectivement il y a des
complicité on est d'accord mais à partir
du moment oùù le club lui a identifié
cité si ce sont des
sociétés des prestataires privés
extérieurs est-ce que vous par exemple
en tant lorsque vous étiez président de
l'Olympique de Marseille vous avez eu
à casser un contrat avec une société
privée du fait que vous savez que vous
saviez que des individus enfin des
individus des personnes de ces sociétés
externes avaient été complices de
l'introduction de fumigène dans le
sadéodrome alors moi j'ai j'ai pas le
souvenir préc j'ai pas envie de dire
dire de bêtises surtout j'ai pris le
parti d'être d'être assez transparent
j'ai le souvenir d'avoir essayé de de
reprendre la commercialisation des
abonnements des groupes de supporters et
ça m'a coûté cher pour mettre en place
une convention le club récupérer le
récupérer la gestion de ses abonnements
et en mettant justement des abonnements
nominatifs ça je peux vous en parler
pendant des jours euh j'ai pas le
souvenir à titre personnel encore une
fois d'avoir remplacé une société
sécurité par une autre ce qui ne veut
pas dire que mes équipes et mon
directeur général de l'époque ne l'a pas
fait donc je veux pas vous voilà
et pour pour pour répondre sur
l'implication des clubs oui elle est
totale alors effectivement ça peut
marcher plus ou moins bien dans un club
que dans un autre la la la progression
des clubs est peut-être pas la même dans
un club ou dans un autre mais oui la la
structuration des clubs sur ces
questionsl et est quand même beaucoup
plus efficace aujourd'hui qu'elle ne
l'était il y a quelques années la
professionnalisation des personnels
privés de
sécurité aussi donc ça on peut s'en
réjouir je voudrais surtout pas avoir
l'air de de plomber l'ambiance par
rapport à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure non les les les la politique que
l'on mène elle marche aussi parce que
nos affluences sont en forte hausse ça
veut dire que les gens se sentent bien
dans les stades de football quand on
parle de 28000 spectateurs en moyenne en
Ligue 1 cette saison c'est aussi parce
que les gens se sentent bien et se
sentent en sécurité
donc oui les clubs sont impliqués après
c'est un c'est un dispositif qui est
complexe mais la prise en compte pour
répondre précisément à votre question et
comme l'a dit
la prise en compte des identifications
et des plaintes nominatives rentre dans
l'appréciation de la commission de
discipline du travail du club et donc de
la sanction qu'elle prononce Infiné
parce que vous parliez des fumigènes il
y a encore beaucoup de fumigènes c'est
extrêmement dangereux il y a surtout
encore beaucoup de fumiggènees alors
même que l'État et la Ligue a fait des
efforts de compréhension vis-à-vis des
supporters en permettant des craquages
de fumigènees encadrés de façon
sécurisée donc donc il y a un pas qui
est fait vers les supporters pour le
moment il y a pas tellement de retour
sur ces questions là il y a pas
tellement de contrepartie mais oui les
les cette cette prise en compte là est
est réelle et sur les interdictions
commerciales de de stade c'est souvent
des abonnements qui sont suspendus donc
il y a une punition financière quand
même qui est pas
négligée le 31 août des représentants
d'association luttant contre
l'homophobie dans le foot ont proposé à
la ministre des Sports de reprendre le
plan de pacification du Parc des Princes
de Robin Leprou mise en œuvre en 2010 et
a abandonné depuis il s'agirait
d'associer la division nationale de
lutte contre l'holiganisme les
responsables de la sécurité des clubs et
des associations dans un dispositif
tripartite des observateurs seraient
placés dans les tribunes et
recenseraient les faits d'homophobie et
de racisme en plus de la captation vidéo
après les match les les fit seraient
retransmis à la commission discipline de
la FP et au procureur de la République
et auprè préfet compétent que
pensez-vous de cette proposition la
ministre a annoncé en audition la
semaine dernière que son cabinet avait
contacté le fcms et la S sa-étienne pour
tester ce dispositif en avez-vous eu
connaissance je vais répondre juste j'ai
j'ai vu à la Fédération Française de
Football la directrice générale du FC
mes pas plus tard que jeudi dernier lors
du COMEX qui m'a fait état effectivement
d'un appel du du ministère des Sports
pour mettre un observateur des matchs à
mes sur ces sujets là donc je vous
confirme que c'est complètement Fortui
que j'en a entendu parler
elle m'a fait une très bonne remarque
elle m'a dit on va se tirer une balle
dans le pied
puisque c'est c'est le club qui va être
sanctionné voilà non mais non mais donc
il faut le faire mais
comment alors c'est que comme toujours
il y a une différence entre l'idée
proposée et la mise en uvre de l'idée et
les conséquences sous les contraintes
juridiques qui se qui sont liées à cette
à cette à cette idée là c'est que
l'association en question qui a
rencontrer effectivement le le la
ministre des Sports pour lui proposer ce
dispositif ça veut dire que vous avez
des agents quels agents dans les
tribunes qui s'occupe de de de de de de
cette observation quel maillage vous
avez sur des stades qui sont extrêmement
volumineux ça veut dire qu'il faut des
un nombre d'observateurs extrêmement euh
grand qui soit assermenté pour que
derrière les observations qu'ils font
puissent être considéré comme crédibl
notamment par rapport au procureurs que
vous citez donc oui toutes les
réflexions ou toutes les idées sont
Bones à prendre celle-ci c'est il faut
la la regarder l'expertiser pourquoi pas
effectivement la tester dans un certain
nombre de stades mais c'est c'est c'est
pas aussi évident que veut bien le dire
l'association en question
c'est
bon non non monsieur Stéphan Mazard vous
avez une
question pas de souci merci madame la
Présidente désolé parce que on est
obligé de de faire des VAERS entre
l'hémicyclle et et et et et votre
audition vos auditions et et et je
risque d'ailleurs de de de mettre les
pieds dans les plats sur un sujet que
vous avez déjà abordé bon je
tent sur les sujets qui nous préoccupent
lutter contre les violences contre les
comportements
sexistes les comportements
discriminatoires homophobes et
[Musique]
cetera il y a peut-être un levier qui
est celui donc de conditionner la
répartition des droits télé en fonction
de critères qui permettrait donc de
mettre de mettre en en en lumière ceux
qui font et ceux qui font moins ceux qui
font
pas alors je sais que ça existe mais
certains considèrent justement que vous
avez baissé un peu pavillon sur la
répartition des droits qui sont
afférents à à à à à à des engagements
sur ces sujets euh donc voilà quel est
votre sentiment sur ce que vous avez
fait sur ce que vous faites sur ce que
vous pourriez faire à ce titre parce que
on on est tous à rechercher des leviers
et et notamment pour responsabiliser les
clubs est-ce que pour vous c'est un bon
levier et est-ce qu'il est suffisamment
activé alors toutes les idées sont Bones
à prendre he comme comme on dit oui on a
un dispositif qui s'appelle la licence
club à la Ligue qui
permet c'est c'est un dispositif
multirritère qui
vient classer les club ou attribuer des
points au club en fonction de tout un
tas de dispositifs ça va du centre de
formation à à la qualité de la pelouse
l'engagement sur les questions
énergétiques la formation des choses
comme ça et on a modifié la licence club
l'année dernière pour mettre sur 10000
points 1000 points sur toutes les
questions de RSE donc on a 1000 points
dans la licence club qui sont soit sur
l'engagement sur les questions de
discrimination par exemple organiser des
séminirees de sensibilisation ça vient
donner des points au club pour augmenter
son total de de points dans la licence
club pareil pour tout ce qui touche à la
sobriété énergétique ou oui et et et et
la licence club représente aujourd'hui
20 % des droits télé voilà donc c'est
pas
directement pour répondre à votre
question c'est pas directement les
droits télé qu'on va affecter si un club
fait un atelier de sensibilisation ils
vont tous le faire ils le font déjà
beaucoup voilà c'est au travers de la
licence club
exactement 10 % tout ce qui est 10 % 10
% représente 20 % 20 % 20 % donc vous
avez raison mais on vient de le faire
qu'on l'a mis en place c'est
déjàou par vous avez raison déjà on
vient de le faire donc c'est une
nouveauté ça va dans dans le sens que
vous préconisez que vous on peut
peut-être sur la durée monter ce
pourcentage
voilà
oui alors j'ai deux petites questions
mais peut-être qu'elles ont été été
abordé la première c'est sur la forme du
modèle économique parce que j'avais cru
comprendre que les 40 clubs je crois
perd avaient perdu environ 600 millions
d'euros ces dernières années donc sur le
modèle en fait comment ça fonctionne
avec des pertes aussi importantes et
comment on fait pour que ça fonctionne
correctement et la deuxième nous a été
beaucoup aussi abordé la question du
soutien au sport amateurs est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui le modèle économique en
tout cas ce qui a été mis en place est
suffisant pour le que pour que le sport
professionnel soutienne correctement le
sport
amateurou sur le deè point du sport
amateur
effectivement il est
nécessaire il et il est sur un TR trois
niveaux il y a ce qu'on appelle
effectivement la la relation entre la
Fédération et la Ligue donc a des
conventions passées entre les ligues et
les fédérations et il y a les ligues qui
le peuvent parce que toutes les ligues
ne génèrent pas des revenus qui leur
permettent effectivement de redistribuer
et notamment à la Fédération donc il y a
ce levier de la redistribution de la de
la Ligue vers la féd il y a évidemment
le levier qu'on connaît tous de la taxe
dite buffet sur la retransmission des
droits audiovisuels et il y a un
troisième levier qui est un peu moins
qui est un peu moins connu qui est celui
que chaque club au niveau du club la la
société reverse à l'association support
et là aussi il y a des conventions
passées notamment financières et donc
sur l'ensemble par des des six
disciplines qui sont les Lig
professionnell avec le statut juridique
propre l'ensemble de ce montant fait à
peu près 223 millions par an 220
millions par an puisque effectivement il
y a 44 millions au titre la taxe buffet
et donc j'allais dire sur les 52
millions de la taxe buffet qui qui est
qui est prise par la par le par 52
millions la taxe buffet il y a donc 44
millions qui viennent qui viennent du
sport professionnel et dont 71 % pour le
seul foot et après il y a c'est les
montants qui sont donnés des ligues vers
les fédérations donc effectivement aussi
un montant identique de 44 millions le
montant éidment le plus important étant
celui que que que le foot reverse à la
Fédération et après il y a 135 millions
qui sont reversés par les associations
par les sociétés sportives au aux
associations support et donc je vous dis
on arrive vers ce avec ces trois ces
trois leviers à ce montant de de près de
220 millions par
an vu que Frédéric a donné les chiffres
du football c'est pas la peine que je
vous les vous les redonne et après sur
la question des du modè non non mais on
per beaucoup d'argent on vous l'z dit en
préambule on a on a traversé une crise
une crise financière économique sans
précédent qu'on paye encore aujourd'hui
un chiffre
entre juin 21 et juin 2022 apport des
actionnaires dans les clubs
1ard289 millions
d'euros au moment de de la crise du
covid à la même date au 30 juin 2022
après l'apport d'unillard280 millions
d'euros dte financière des clubs 1
milliard 065 million d'euros pour vous
montrer la gravité de la situation quand
on sait qu'on est le pilier du
financement du sport amateur du football
amateur et aussi d'une partie du
mouvement olympique donc on on était
dans une situation dramatique qui nous a
conduit d'ailleurs à faire un choix fort
de créer cette société commerciale et de
faire rapport à un investisseur privé
pour avoir un milliard et demi dans dans
nos caisses pour permettre à nos clubs
de survivre tout l'objectif c'est quoi
l'objectif c'est d'éviter évidemment la
faillite de nos locomotives de leur
donner de la force qu'ell soit de plus
en plus compétitive notamment à
l'international pour pour qu'on augmente
nos revenus
internationaux qu'on soit plus
performant qu'on at tire plus de talent
qu'on augmente nos revenus domestiques
et que dans ce cadre là la pyramide le
ruissellement se fasse de façon optimale
vers la Fédération Française de Football
d'une part et vers les autres
disciplines d'autre part donc oui on a
un rôle majeur majeur pour tout le sport
français on en a parfaitement conscience
j'avais pas les mêmes chiffres que toi
quand tu as dit 71 % pour le foot donc
moi je dois avoir les recettes
internationales en plus pour moi les
chiffres que j'ai mais je veux pas dire
de bêtises faut que je fasse attention
de mon point de vue en intégrant le
National et l' International le football
fait plus de 80 % des recette de
l'ensemble du sport français et je crois
même que c'est plutôt supérieur à 85
mais encore une fois si je fais erreur
autant pour moi mais c'est de ça qu'on
parle donc notre responsabilité elle est
majeure on on se doit d'éviter la
faillite de notre système c'est on est
encore dedans on perd effectivement le
chiffre de 600 millions et quelques
c'est le chiffre de l'an passé je pense
qu'il va être encore pire cette saison
voilà faut pas avoir peur de de le dire
faut affronter les réalités en face
c'est pour ça qu'on fait un travail de
de réforme important il y a une crise
économique majeure au niveau mondial
pour autant pour autant on travaille on
est en pleine négociation des droits
télé aujourd'hui c'est pas facile on on
sera encore sans doute obligé de faire
appel aux actionnaire ou à la vente de
joueurs pour équilibrer la les comptes
dans les dans dans l'été prochain mais
mais mais on a bien idée on a on a
vraiment la volonté euh de rentrer dans
un cercle vertueux qui passe c'est ce
que je voulais dire plus en détail dans
mon introduction mais c'était pas le
sujet de la commission qui passe par
l'augmentation de nos performances
sportives plus nos clubs seront
compétitifs sur la scène européenne plus
on ira capter les recettes européennes
parce que en
fait les recettes sont en fonction de
tes résultats plus on va capter de
l'argent des compétitions européennes
plus on va capter de l'argent des droits
internationaux plus on va avoir des
moyens par rapport à nos concurrents
plus on va recruter des talents plus on
va pouvoir garder nos meilleurs joueurs
plus on va augmenter le niveau de
spectacle et niveau de comptivé de notre
club plus on va peut-être attirer des
investisseurs en tout état de cause plus
le spectacle sera bon et plus on
augmentera no revenus audiovisuel et
plus toute la collectivité pourra en
bénéficier et dans un monde idéal
optimal on doit avoir des droits qu'
augmentent de
façon ininterrompu c'est pas le cas en
ce moment mais qu'est-ce qu'on compte
faire on compte s'améliorer déjà
sportivement fait ça reste du sport
malgré tout Stéphan oui mais là
justement monsieur la brune ou on est
quand même un petit peu inquiet quand on
est un amateur nous sommes des amateurs
de football euh de voir se profiler
effectivement le marché des droits télé
euh bon on n'est pas hyper optimiste on
voit quand même que euh on perd des
audiences on perd
euh de la qualitéin avec des grands
joueurs qui aujourd'hui euh
préfèrent préfèrent partir jouer donc
dans des pays qui ont pas une culture du
football comme comme on peut l'avoir ou
comme d'autres pays européens long euh
h est-ce que ce sont des éléments qui
qui vous inquiètent aujourd'hui et et
est-ce que est-ce que ça fait partie de
la réflexion de dire peut-être que
demain le foot paillette ben c'est pas
celui c'est pas celui qu'on va réussir à
vendre parce qu'on ne sera pas
concurrentiel avec d'autres pays et
qu'il faut peut-être effectivement avoir
un plan B un plan C mais qui reste à à
définir hein ENF je là là je fa je c'est
partage ENF l'inquiétude que que nous on
peut avoir quand on est amateur de
football et et qu'on s'interroge sur et
puis puis il faut faut le reconnaître
aussi on a quand même
parfois on est désabusés quoi quand
quand un match est interrompu quand un
match se joue pas
euh quand on a un match où on n pas de
plaisir à y aller en famille même à
Ligue 2 parce que le match va démarrer 1
heure plus tard parce que les supporters
se foutent sur la gueule avant le coup
d'envoie enfin voilà on a des images
quand même qui font que on a on y vient
parfois voilà en se disant est-ce que on
va ressortir indem bon ça c'est dans le
pire des cas mais est-ce que il va pas y
avoir des des propos à minima ou ou des
scènes qui vont traumatiser les gamins
qu'on a vocation à mener et à éduquer
dans les dans les
stades tout est lié vous avez
raison je vais rester sur sur le
sportif le football professionnel
français c'est une vue de l'esprit que
de dire depuis 20 ans qu'on est en dans
le Big Five il y a pas de Big Five il y
a un Big Four et il y a la France qui
est en 2ème division européenne un
chiffre on n pas gagné une seule coupe
d'Europe depuis 1993 euh si on fait rien
si on reste comme ça si on reste avec
cette approche
franco-française avec des droits
domestiques qui sont pas exponentiels on
va mourir notre belle mort et on pourra
plus financer l'ensemble du système
c'est pour ça qu'on a pris le parti avec
Arnaud avec les équipes de la ligue et
avec notre partenaire de relancer un
projet sportif ambitieux qui est qui est
officiel qui est de mettre le football
français de club euh sur le podium
européen à minima d'ici 2027-228 euh
pourquoi on pense qu'il vont y arriver
parce qu'on pense comme vous et vous
l'avez dit fort justement qu'il y a de
plus en plus de joueurs qui vont partir
dans des nouveaux eldoradoos financiers
mais finalement c'est pas une si
mauvaise chose pour nous parce que nous
historiquement c'est la France le
vendeur de talent qui partait en
Angleterre en Italie en Espagne en
Allemagne aujourd'hui on voit que les
plus grands joueurs du monde finalement
ils partent aujourd'hui vers le
Moyen-Orient en Arabie Saoudite demain
peut-être aux États-Unis et nous on a un
vivier
un vivier de jeunes joueurs on a une
qualité de formation qui nous donne un
potentiel de notre point de vue
inépuisable on fabrique plus de talents
que les autres nation on a des super
infrastructures on a un projet ambitieux
on espère en augmentant notre
compétitivité donc nos revenus demain
qu'on va avoir moyen de convaincre nos
jeunes talents de rester plus longtemps
avec nous d'en faire revenir d'autres
c'est déjà le cas depuis 2 ans on a un
certain nombre de joueurs qui sont
revenus de l'étranger pour venir en
France on a beaucoup moins qui sont
partis donc on a l'espoir si si
l'objectif c'est de rester 5e ou 6e vous
avez tout à fait raison fa qu'on passe à
autre chose il y aura plus de place pour
5 ou si top nation en Europe au niveau
économique dans les années à venir par
contre deux ou trois oui on y croit et
on croit qu'on a les at tout pour le
faire et ça passera aussi par une
collaboration accrue avec l'État parce
qu'on a quand même des boulets au pied
je dis souvent les charges sociales sur
les salaires on est pas on est dans une
compétition globale et on n pas les
mêmes charges que les
autres mais si on a une ambition commune
si tout le monde est derrière et envie
encore une fois de mettre notre football
de club au niveau de notre football de
sélection nationale et ben on va amener
du bonheur aux gens et on va vivre des
des épopées européennes fantastiques ça
va marquer l'imaginaire collectif il y a
eu deux matchs génials cette année
géniaux pardon Toulouse Liverpool
c'était une fête incroyable à Toulouse
j'étais au match et l'autre je l'ai vu à
la télé c'était lance Arsenal on voyait
les enfants moi ça m'a fait plaisir
c'était super c'était des grands moment
al c'était un peu le petit Pousset cont
mais bon c'est ça vers ça qu'on doit
aller et c'est ça qui rassemble les gens
et je pense qu'on on a on a les bons
partenaires on a des clubs qui sont
déterminés on a bâti les fondations
d'une vraie ambition et d'unra projet et
on pense qu'on peut y arriver le marché
audiovisuel il est très compliqué très
très très compliqué puisquil est
directement relié à la crise économique
et financière planétaire les premiers
touchés c'est les consommateurs lambda
on tout simplement plus les moyens de
payer des abonnements qui préfèrent
garder l'argent pour leurs enfants la
nourriture choses comme ça donc on va
subir un peut-être un contrecou mais
tout le monde va le subir c'est pas ça
le problème c'est c'est pas que la
France c'est pas un
microclimat différent des autres donc
nous on y croit on croit au projet on
croit à la force de notre pays on croit
à nos différences on croit à notre
talent on croit à la force de notre
diversité et on croit aussi aux valeurs
aux valeurs et qu'il faut qu'on doit
marteler et pour faire un football
différent et plus festif et plus
familial et voilà c'est c'est c'est ça
le projet on est on espère qu'on y
arrivera madame la
rapporteur peut-être une question
complémentaire justement à ce modèle
économique qu'on a évoqué donc ces
fameux 600 millions qui risque vous
l'avez dit de d' êre pire pour l'année
qui arrive est-ce que au-delà de la
question des contrats de droits
audiovisuel et il y a des économies qui
ont été envisagé je vous dis ça parce
que il y a il y a eu beaucoup de
d'articles sont sortis notamment sur
l'achat d'un siège je crois pour une
somme de 127 millions
d'euros il y a quelques mois de ça donc
peut-être voilà il y avait peut-être des
des poches d'économie à faire mais
peut-être que le choix a été fait en de
manière stratégique donc si vous pouvez
nous exp expliquer un peu comment ça
s'est
fait pardon en préambule plutôt que de
faire des des réflexions sur les
économies on est plutôt dans une phase
de développement de nos ressources donc
on a pris un partenaire CVC Capital avec
nous on on s'est professionnalisé on a
embauché certains talents à nos côtés et
on a fait aujourd'hui un accord par
qu'on commence et on vend pas des droits
tous les jours euh sur les droits
internationaux on a passé le montant on
avait 11 millions d'euros par an sur 3
ans on l'a passé à 33 millions d'euros
sur 5 ans donc aujourd'hui on est plus
en train de se professionnaliser pour
essayer d'augmenter nos ressources et
nos revenus parce qu'on était quand même
dans un fonctionnement avec 7080
personnes à la Ligue c'éit quand même
très régalien très administratif là où
les ligues concurrentes avaient des
centaines de collaborateurs on va plutôt
essayer de d'investir sur le le
personnel madame le rapporteur pour
développer nos ressources de nos
recettes de façon exponentielle plutôt
que d'essayer de faire des des économies
sur le sur le le siège Arnaud je te
laisse sur le sur le projet de siège la
réalité aujourd'hui de la Ligue c'est
qu'on est propriétaire de notre siège
actuel qui est aussi suru de liib et on
loue trois appartements dans le bas de
la rue au 88 avenue Cléber donc le
personnel de la Ligue é pararpillé on va
dire sur le 6 rulé au de lib le 88
avenue Cléber TR appart et mon petit
gazon qui est une entreprise que la la
filièale commerciale a racheté qui est
dans le dans le 9e donc il y a une
volonté de de de de fusionner et de de
rationaliser en en déménageant pour
mettre tout le monde au même endroit la
question a été posée au conseil
d'administration de savoir s'il fallait
aller sur un dispositif de location ou
d'achat et le conseil d'administration a
fait le choix d'aller sur un dispositif
d'achat puisque essayons d'être positif
il y aura encore du football dans 20 ans
et s'engager à fond perdu sur un loyer
pour tous nos membres du conseil
d'administration et de la G qui sont des
présidents de club qui sont des chefs
d'entreprise ont dit bon ben
investissant dans un siège oui c'est un
siège qui est onéreux mais qui est un
placement sans risque boulevard courcell
on a visité plusieurs endroits dans
Paris d'autres endroits qui étaient plus
abordables dans le 11e notamment mais
qui en terme de risque financier était
pas tout à fait pareil donc c'est un
placement très onéreux vous l'avez dit
mais euh qui est un placement raisonné
et qui permet de sécuriser un
investissement pour la Ligue et de
constituer ses actifs
pardon Stéphane
bchou de Stéphane c'est c'est
confusant non dans le prolongement dans
le prolongement de de de ce qu'a dit mon
mon collègue Stéphane Mazar qui qui a de
ce qu' a très bien dit d'ailleurs mon
collègue Stéphan Mazar sur sur les
inquiétudes sur les inquiétudes alors
moi j'entends votre enthousiasme et et
on peut le on peut effectivement on peut
effectivement le partager non mais vous
n'êtes pas sans sans ignorer qu'il a il
y a de nombreuses interrogations qui se
posent sur sur les droit télé sur la
répartition des droits télé parce que ça
aussi c'est un sujet qu'on a pas abordé
mais que enfin sur lequel moi j'aimerais
le cas échéant vous entendre sur voilà
comment est-ce que cette somme elle est
elle est elle est ventilée entre entre
les clubs euh je suis un gros club je
suis un petit club bon euh ensuite sur
vous il y a eu un un début de de
d'explication sur sur le football sur le
football amateur
euh et puis sur la sur les négociations
qui sont qui sont en cours parce que il
y a quelques années on nous avait on
nous avait vendu et venté l'accord je
crois que Mia c'était Mia sport Mia pro
pardon
à hauteur d'un milliard on a on a vu
comment ça s'est terminé queles sont
aujourd'hui quels sont aujourd'hui dans
le cadre des négociations qui sont en
cours est-ce que vous avez est-ce que
vous avez tiré les conséquences de cet
échec et et quelles sont les garde de
fou que vous avez mis en en œuvre ou pas
pour ne pas que ça se
reproduise bah il est pas question que
ça se reproduise donc on va essayer de
pas faire deux fois les mêmes bêtises
sinon on serait vraiment des idiots donc
je pense qu'en terme notamment de
garanties juridiques et financières qui
sont demandé aux acteurs il y a un
effort tout particulier qui qui est fait
mais encore une fois vous l'avez bien vu
le processus d'appel d'offre a été
infructueux le 17 octobre malgré une
marque d'intérêt très forte non pas d'un
acteur de deux mais plutôt de quatre ou
CIN par
plus la difficulté c'est de
convaincre les investisseurs les
broadcaseurs à investir sur notre
produit dans un marché qui est très
complexe très compliqué donc avant de se
dire aujourd'hui toi telle garantie
telle garantie telle garantie on va déjà
essayer de trouver quelqu'un je vous
rassure on a des gens mais ça c'est le
secret des affaires on est en pleine
discussion avec un certain nombre d'
d'acteurs et on va faire en sorte bien
évidemment de pas s'associer avec un un
partenaire qui ne donnerait pas de
sécurité à la LFP en cas de défaut de
paiement comme ça a été le cas
malheureusement en
2020 à notre arrivée et je le regrette
sachez-le très fortement la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on est on s'en est
sorti
on les clubs sont toujours là notre
compétitivité européenne se progresse et
qu'on a quand même des raisons d'espérer
ça aurait pu être bien pire
donc vous partagez pas un grand
optimismeite c'est à nous d'être
optimiste c'est à nous d'être ambitieux
et c'est à nous de faire en sorte qu'on
d'y croire et de renverser à la table
monsieur le député mais je vous entends
mer merci à vous
messieurs allez derni j'y vais madame la
Présidente bon euh
oui toujours sur le modèle économique
des clubs des clubs de Ligue 1 euh il y
a quelques années je pense qu'on il y
avit une tendance qui visait à à ce que
les clubs s'approprient l'infrastructure
sportive
pour développer justement du business au
travers l'infrastructure modèle anglais
modèle allemand modèle Lonis est-ce que
c'est quelque chose c'est une tendance
aujourd'hui que vous essayez
d'accompagner ce qui permet d'ailleurs
un désengagement des collectivités
locales lorsque les sports sont
matures on pense à la Ligue 1 ou au Top
14 par exemple
voilà avec l'approche c'est plus au
collectivité locale de financer le le
sport professionnel de niveau comme
c'est pas à l'état de venir en aide au
football professionnel quand il
traversent une crise pour payer les
salaires de nos joueurs l'État do donner
de l'argent aux hôpitaux aux gens qu'on
on besoin mais pas à nous c'est à nous
de nous prendre en main ça on est bien
d'accord dans le modèle est-ce que
évidemment que ça fait sens de posséder
son infrastructure et son stade encore
faut-il en avoir les moyens c'est pour
ça qu'aussi dans le projet qui est le
nôtre on essaie d'attirer un certain
nombre de nouveaux investisseurs non pas
parce qu'ils sont mieux ou plus sympas
tout simplement parce qu'ils sont
peut-être un peu plus fortunés que
certains actionnaires historiques qui
n'ont pas les moyens de se porter à
créur de leur stade ou ou d'en
construire un mais effectivement sur le
le moyen et le long
terme il faudrait idéalement que que que
que chaque club prenne soit propriétaire
de de de son stade avec de l'argent
privé c'est c'est le point pour essayer
d'être positif par rapport à aux
questions que que vous posez sur lequel
nous on est optimiste c'est que sur les
infrastructures euh on est très très
bien la France depuis le début des
années 2000 a entamé une vague de de
rénovation des infrastructures en lien
avec les clubs
et aujourd'hui le parc d'équipement on
va dire des clubs est de grande qualité
comparativement à l'Italie par exemple
qui qui a un parc de stade extrêmement
vieillissant donc aujourd'hui
l'infrastructure c'est c'est moteur pour
attirer du public dans les stades les
gens ils viennent plus dans un stade
pour avoir froid sur une galette en
plein hiver et puis manger un sandwich
foid
quoi une prie niveau économique on le
voit tous au quotidien et ça se
répercute effectivement sur sur notre
économie à nous mais c'est peut-être
c'est moins important au final par
contre pour le futur du football
français on a vraiment des atouts les
stades AR vient de le dire la formation
incroyable le vivier la
diversité de ces talents des nouveaux
des nouveaux actionnaires qui sont venus
aussi l'équipe nationale c'est une
référence c'est une marque forte on a
quand même pas mal d'atout on a rien à
envier à nos concurrents alors je dis
pas qu'on a tout mal fait avant mais en
tout cas aujourd'hui on essayer de le
faire peut-être différemment avec une
autre approche et et on pense qu'on a
autant d'atou voir plus que certains de
nos voisins pour demain revenir en haut
de la scène voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire
dernière juste je je j'avoue ne ne pas
avoir bien
compris ce que vous nous avez dit
Monsieur la brune tout à l'heure
sur les le fait que la France était une
pépinière vous avez raison euh enfin
vous avez pas employé ce terme là c'est
c'est c'est le mien inv vivier pardon
bon c'est le jeu des synonym de de de
joueur
talentueux moi ce qui m' je vous rassure
je suis optimiste mais ce qui
m'interroge quand même c'est que vous
parliez tout à l'heure d'un système
vertueux en matière d'investissement de
de de flux de flux jeis au bout de mon
raisonnement de flux économique qui
devrait et on le souhaite souit tous
rejaillir sur les résultats sportifs là
où j'ai une petite interrogation mais ça
ne reste qu'une interrogation c'est si
on prend un exemple que vous connaissez
mieux que nous celui du parissaggermain
qui met beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent sur la table depuis
maintenant plus de 10
ans le résultat c'est qu'ils sont ils
sont quasiment champions de France tous
les ans
euh pardon non c'est pratiquement
pratiquement diffenet avec les
autresêreampion les an on trouvé le de
je
je la beauté non non mais c'était ce que
ce que je veux dire ce que ce que je
veux vous dire par là c'est que
effectivement et on le partage vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que beaucoup de
joueurs talentueux aujourd'hui partent
vers des destinations plus exotiques du
type Moyen-Orient
entre autres ou
États-Unis comment malgré l'arrivée
d'investisseur dont vous avez parlé tout
à l'heure comment est-ce qu'on fait
demain pour concurrencer parce que il
s'agit de ça pour oui pour concurrencer
ces pays-là
si on a déjà presque un peu de retard si
le retard s'accentue vous nous dites que
vous êtes en négociation c'est les
affaires ok très bien vous êtes en
négociation on ne sait pas comment ça va
atterrir on le saura je pense dans dans
dans quelques semaines mais ce gap qui
pourrait le cas
échéant oui non mais c'est ça et et et
vous disiez tout à l'heure et on encore
une fois on partage ça on n pas le
dernier club qui a gagné une Coupe
d'Europe une ligue des champions vous le
connaissez à juste titre c'est
l'Olympique de Marseille et C en 93 il y
a 25
ans il y a il y a 30 ans pardon
excusez-moi il y a 30 ans voilà c'était
c'était c'est à la fois une réflexion et
une observation et une question c'est
c'est euh
est-ce qu'on peut considérer
que l'afflux d'argent va nécessairement
avoir pour conséquence que le niveau
sportif va s'élever que les titres vont
affluer moi je vous avoue malgré un
optimisme constant que je m'interroge
malgré tout ok je vais faire vite bon
déjà le football c'est c'est une
question d'argent pas que mais be oup
quand même non non mais beaucoup quand
même si vous il y a pas j'ai pas
d'exemple en tête vous en sortirez sans
doute un depuis ces dernières années ou
un ou ou un club qui avait pas de des
revenus importants à gagneré la Ligue
des Champions parle donc ça m me permet
d'ouvrir sur le parisgermain
euh le paris-germain c'est une chance
unique incroyable qu'il soit en France
depuis 2011 sinon je serai pas je sais
pas où serait le football français voilà
les investissement qu'on fait le PSG les
points UEFA qu'ils ont gagné ce qui nous
permet aujourd'hui d'être en situation
d'avoir quatre places qualificatives en
Ligue des Champions la saison prochaine
avec les revenus inhérents à la
qualification l'investissement qu'ils
ont fait à travers billet avec bin sport
je vous le
promets par l'État du Qatar on doit leur
dire merci le football français puisqueà
un moment très compliqué ils sont avec
nous c'est nos partenaires et on est
heureux de les avoir avec nous ça c'est
la première chose deuxièmement pour
rebondir sur le parisgermain si on veut
plus de performance faut garder nos
talents qu'est-ce qu'ils font c'est quoi
le plus jeune talent aujourd'hui du
paris-sint-germain c'est plus qu'il a
Mbappé c'est Zair Emer Zair Emer il a 16
ans il a 17 ans et encore quelques
années ce même joueur il serait parti en
Allemagne comme l'a fait daoamcano ou
comme l'a fait Kingley coman ou comme
l'ont fait d'autres très jeunes talents
qui sont allés renforcer des équipes
allemandes ou allemandes essentiellement
je va vous poser une question est-ce que
vous croyez une
seconde un gamin de 17 17 ans c'est de
ça qu'on parle 18 ans qui a grandi avec
sa famille en bieu parisienne elle s'est
elle se réveille un matin dit tiens j'ai
envie d'aller jouer en Allemagne cyz
qu'il va aller là-bas pour quoi pour le
climat non pour la langue B non il en
parle pas il va pour il va pourquoi à
votre avis hein mais pourquoi il y va
posez-vous la question pourquoi ils vont
en Allemagne parce qu'en Allemagne il y
a pas de charge sociale donc le salaire
brut qui est proposé c'est salaire net
pour le joueur on a perdu un certain
nombre de joueurs à cause de la
disparité fiscale entre un pays comme la
France et l'Allemagne des jeuneseurs
aujourd'hui le pariss-germain dans sa
nouvelle stratégie de faire revenir des
stars de l'équipe de France à Paris sur
le territoire national en France et de
garder ses jeunes joueurs et ben il y a
quelques annéesemr c'est peut-être parti
en Allemagne déjà ou je sais pas où mais
en l'occurrence il est là aujourd'hui on
est fier de lui c'est un petit français
qui est en équipe de France qui a été le
plus jeune joueur le plus jeune marqueur
de l'équipe de France et aujourd'hui
c'est tous ces talents là comprennent le
projet et notre ambition et qu'on arrive
à être fier de notre pays on n'est pas
des nuls en foot on est super bon et et
si on arrive à à bien travailler tous
ensemble ils vont rester chez nous ils
vont rester chez nous parce qu'ils vont
être fiers de porter nos couleurs parce
qu'on va avoir des moyens financiers à
peu près équivalents aux autres modulo
effectivement différentiel de charge et
c'est comme ça qu'on va être plus
compétitif s'ils reste avec nous un on
est meilleur et en plus ils sont pas
avec les autres c'est c'est quand même
le seul sport le foot c'est quètement
dingue où tous les ans historiquement
les équipes françaises depuis 20 ans et
se qualifi en Coupe d'Europe première
chose qu'il faisaent ils vendaent leur
meilleur joueur au club espagnol mais
vous en connaissez beaucoup des secteurs
d'activité où vous avez un super brevet
vous dites tiens demain je vais le
vendre à mon concurrent allemand ou
espagnol donc nous on vendait nos
meilleurs joueurs aux concurrents
étrangers qui allit après nous battre
sur la scène européenne non mais c'est
c'est donc c'est c'est aussi tout ça
qu'il faut changer et ça reste une
question de moyens malgré tout et on
essaie d'apporter des moyens indnel
alors c'est comme ça c'est vrai mais en
ce moment c'est compliqué mais on on est
assez optimiste par la suite
voilà merci à vous messieurs euh on on
vous demandera juste si vous le
souhaitez euh nous apporter une
contribution écrite pour pour nous
transmettre vos recommandations à cette
commission d'enquête
plaisir avec grand plaisir très bien
merci sous quel
délai oui cour la
semaineà fin de semaine début de semaine
prochaine d'ord parfait merci à vous
merci